[Musique]
Pierre Connaissa, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Serview. Nous
sommes en direct. Nous vous recevons
dans votre dans le cadre de votre
capacité à décrypter le l'Arabie
Saoudite, la radicalisation et tous ces
sujets connexes. Est-ce que vous voulez
vous présenter succintement ?
Euh bon ben je m'appelle Pierre Conessa.
Moi j'ai fait une grande partie de ma
vie professionnelle dans j'ai enseigné
pendant 5 ans. Ensuite j'ai fait une
grande partie de ma vie professionnelle
dans la haute administration.
La plus longue période étant au
ministère de la défense. Et puis euh
j'ai fini les 10 dernières années de ma
vie professionnelle en dirigeant une
société d'intelligence économique. Bon
c'est-à-dire que
tout le le fil le fil conducteur si vous
voulez c'est la connaissance et la
transmission de la connaissance. Et ce
qui est la partie finale de ma vie
professionnelle, c'est l'intelligence
économique, c'est des entreprises qui
posent une question précise à laquelle
il faut répondre de manière précise et
dont il l'entreprise est un propriétaire
du de la chose. Pourquoi je dis ça ?
C'est parce que le le sujet dont on va
parler aujourd'hui est revenu vers moi
après la publication de mon livre sur
l'Arabie Saoudite
qui s'appelle
qui s'appelle Docteur Saoud et Mrister
Jjihad, la diplomatie religieuse de
l'Arabie Saoudite.
Bon, ce livre avait provoqué un certain
nombre de vagues. C'est bizarre,
l'Arabie Saoudite, l'ambassade m'a
jamais invité. Pourtant, j'avais demandé
rendez-vous mais ils m'ont jamais
invité.
Euh j'ai eu après ça une note une note
extrêmement incendiaire du centre
d'analyse et de prévision du Korsier sur
mon bouquin qui m'accusait d'être
saoudophobe.
Donc je leur ai répondu que je pensais
que c'était d'être saoudophile qui était
un problème mais visiblement à
l'intérieur du Kedorse, il y a des gens
qui sont des défenseurs acharnés de
l'Arabie Saoudite pour des raisons sur
lesquelles on reviendra.
Et donc après les choses se sont
enchaînées et puis là je viens de
terminer donc un rapport sur le lobby
saoudien en France parce que la commande
était passé avant Kashogi et elle s'est
poursuivie après Kashogi. Bon
alors Kachogi qui était
alors Kachogi était un de ses c'est
comment dire un membre d'une famille
proche du pouvoir assez riche famille de
milliardaires.
C'est celui qui est passé en vi d'Aché
là. Alors, c'est donc lui, c'est ce que
les shaouiens appellent un prince félon,
c'est-à-dire un type qui connaît le
système de l'intérieur mais qui une fois
qu'il en est sorti ou de l'étranger
commence à critiquer le système. Bon, et
vous connaissez son histoire. Le type,
il va faire au consulat de d'Arabie
Saoudite à Istanbul, il va demander un
un papier parce queil veut se remarier.
Et puis vous connaissez la suite de
l'histoire, il est arrêté, torturé,
dépessé. Mohamed surde Mohamed Ben
Salman l'écarisseur c'est lui qui a
demandé que on le ramène en petit
morceau. Et puis
ça a été prouvé ça.
Ah bah oui parce que ce que le Saoudien
ne savaient pas c'est que le consulat
était totalement sonorisé par les
services turcs. C'est-à-dire que vite
les les Turcs, la femme de la future
femme de Kachogi était dehors. Donc
quand elle a vu qu'il sortait pas, elle
a commencé à s'inquiéter. Elle était
voir la police turque et cetera. Donc
l'histoire est montée jusqu'à Erdogan et
c'est les Turcs ont parfaitement géré
l'information qu'il possédait sur le cas
de la de Kachogi. Donc dans un premier
temps, les Saoudiens ont dit "Mais non,
il a quitté le truc, regardez, il y a
des images vidéos dehors." Et les Turcs
ont dit "Oui, mais regardez, c'est pas
lui." C'est-à-dire que ils avaient leurs
propres images. Alors après, ils ont dit
"Non, non, mais en fait, il est parti
dans une autre direction et les Turc ont
dit non, il est pas sorti et cetera et
cetera." C'est-à-dire qu'en lâchant des
petits morceaux d'information comme ça,
ils ont obligé l'Arabie Saoudite à
reconnaître qu'effectivement il n'était
pas sorti et que il est l'en particulier
il ils avaient filmé qu'arrivait une
dizaine une équipe d'une dizaine de
personnes qui en plus sont repartis tous
ensemble dans un van et donc même s'il
voulait raconter que le mec était dans
le van, s'il était dans le van, il était
en morceau, il était dans des petites
valises, il était pas en entier quoi. Et
donc c'est comme ça que le scandale est
sorti. C'est-à-dire qu'on s'est rendu
compte que il y avait d'une part le
meurtre, l'assassinat d'un type à
l'étranger, que le pouvoir était
complètement impliqué dans cette
affaire. Et puis phénomène qui m'a
d'autant plus intéressé, c'est que
Kachogi était le 5e de la catégorie.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y avait eu quatre
autres types qui avaient exactement des
profils identiques qui ont purement et
simplement disparu. Il y en a deux, mais
ça c'est des comment dire des habitudes
saoudiennes dont ils peuvent pas se
défaire. Il y en a deux qui sont partis
en avion avec des avions loués par le
l'ambassade. Il y en a un qui est parti
de du Maroc avec un avion, il pensait
s'atterrir à Rome, il a atterri à Jedda.
Bon, et puis ensuite on a plus de
nouvelles de lui. Il y en a un autre
pareil, il est monté dans un avion
jusqu' Italie et puis pareil, il s'est
retrouvé en Arabie Saoudite. Ces types
ont disparu. Pourquoi je signale ça ?
C'est parce que Cachogi c'est le numéro
5. Mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on a pas
parlé des quatre précédents ? On n pas
parlé des quatre précédents parce que
les journaux se disent "Mais attendez,
c'est une histoire de milliardaires
saoudiens. Qui voulez-vous que ça
intéresse ? Donc tu vois le truc,
c'est-à-dire quand je dis que c'est une
société protégée, c'est que c'est une
société vis-à-vis de laquelle nous avons
des réactions y compris médiatiques qui
ne sont pas de même nature que ce qu'on
va trouver sur d'autres pays. Voilà.
On peut faire le parallèle avec Skripal.
Ah ben on peut faire un parallèle
formidable avec Scripal puisque Scripal
pour ceux qui s'en souviennent
c'était un ancien agent du KGB qui avait
effectivement fait d'éfection et qui
était donc devenu un agent double et qui
avait renseigné les Britanniques et qui
avait demandé le statut de réfugié
politique en Grande-Bretagne.
Les le Gru ou le je sais plus enfin le
FSB a décidé de l'éliminer et donc ils
ont fait cette opération en choisissant
de l'empoisonner au polonium 250. C'est
pas la technique la plus simple mais
enfin en tout cas ils ont fait quelque
chose qui a fait que physiquement le
type est très vite s'est dégradé, il a
perdu ses cheveux, les hôpitaux anglais
comprenaient pas ce qui lui arrivait et
donc c'est devenu une affaire policière
dans laquelle ils ont remonté le truc.
C'était pas du polonium, c'était du
Novichok.
Bah Novitchok, tu connais la combinaison
du cocktail ? Bon enfin bon, peu
importe. Donc c'était quelque chose qui
a donné les signes d'une mort visible.
C'est ça qui était très étonnant. Donc
la l'investigation
l'investigation de la police anglaise a
amené au fait qu'effectivement il avait
été empoisonné de telle et telle
manière. Donc sanction contre la Russie,
contre les oligarques russes, saisit
d'un certain nombre d'avoirs
d'oligarques russes à l'étranger. Enfin
le type en a réchappé. Sa fille qui
était avec lui a aussi souffert mais
enfin elle en a réchappé. Si tu mets ça
en rapport avec ce qui s'est passé
Cachogi, c'est-à-dire que le type est
ressorti mais en morceau est mort, on se
dit "Mais pourquoi les mêmes sanctions
n'ont-elles pas été prises par les
grandes démocraties européennes ? C'est
donc il y a quelque chose qui
effectivement doit s'expliquer. Et
ensuite, tu as vu la façon dont on
réagit, les Américains, les Français et
cetera. Il y a même eu cette phrase
extraordinaire de notre président de la
République disant "Mais n'a rien à voir
avec le Yémen." C'est-à-dire que dans la
campagne de de d'extraordinaire émotion
que ça a créé, là où les Allemands ont
décidé qu'effectivement on ne pouvait
pas garder avec l'Arabie Saoudite des
rapports de même nature, donc arrêter en
particulier les exportations d'armes, la
France a dit "Non, non, ça n'a rien à
voir." Et cela dit, aujourd'hui, il y a
aucune sanction contre l'Arabie
Saoudite.
Comment ça se fait ? Alors, c'est une
c'est une c'est c'est un sujet en soi.
C'est un sujet en soi. Donc, je me suis
intéressé à cette question, c'est-à-dire
comment fonctionne ce qu'on pourrait
appeler le lobby saouien en France ?
Alors, première chose, il faut bien se
rendre compte que euh l'histoire de
l'Arabie Saoudite sur le plan de la
communication est une histoire longue.
C'est-à-dire qu'au départ, les Saoudiens
pensaient que maîtriser la presse
arabophone, c'était déjà une bonne
acquis, ça suffisait. Bon, premier choc
pour eux, c'est la constitution
d'Algzira par le Qatar. C'est-à-dire le
petit dernier qui arrive, qui est plein
de pognon, qui crée une chaîne qui
commence à acquérir une notoriété
professionnelle. Bon, et qui donne la
parole, qui passe les vidéos de Ben
Laden, qui donne la parole à des
opposants et cetera. Ça ça a été un choc
pour l'Arabie Saoudite. C'est-à-dire
qu'il y avait une un média en arabe, en
anglais et bien qui était capable de
faire de la formation mais d'origine
arabe. Les Saoudiens évidemment
tétanisés commencent à essayer de
réagir. Enfin, ils ont essayé d'empêcher
Alzira. Puis finalement, ils ont créé à
l'arra leur première réaction.
Deuxème choc, c'est le 11 septembre. Le
11 septembre, formidable coup de
communication puisqueil y a 15 saoudiens
sur 19 dans les avions qui tombent sur
le World Trade Center. Mais la phrase de
bouche est extraordinaire parce que 2
mois plus tard, il dit c'est l'Iran,
l'Irak et la Corée du Nord. Tu vois la
tête des Nord-Coréens quand ils ont
appris que c'est ils étaient impliqués.
Ça veut dire qu'il y avait déjà aux
États-Unis une comment dire un lobby
capable de faire que le président des
États-Unis qui avait tous les éléments
d'accusation de l'Arabie Saoudite
préfère détourner le tir. Il fait même
beaucoup plus puisque le Congrès se
saisit de la chose. Le Congrès fait un
rapport sur les le 11 septembre qui a
quand même été un choc gigantesque aux
États-Unis he il faut quand même
comprendre que les États-Unis ont jamais
connu la guerre sur leur territoire. Le
dernier mec qui a fait la guerre de
sécession est mort 1955. Donc c'est tu
vois ce que je veux dire ? Le territoire
a été sanctuarisé. Donc ce coup était
très fort pour le Congrès fait un un
rapport dans lesquels il y a 28 pages
consacrées à la responsabilité que les
Saoudiens. George Bouche les classes
secret défense. C'est-à-dire que pendant
28 pendant jusqu'à Obama ces 28 pages
ont été tenues à l'écart de la l'opinion
publique américaine. Donc il y a une il
y a une mécanique sur place qui est
suffisamment puissante pour Donc si tu
veux le fil est parti de ça.
C'est-à-dire comment puisqu'il a eu ce
magnifique succès en Arabie Saoudite aux
États-Unis que se passe-t-il en France ?
Et en fait, il y a un certain nombre de
règles si tu veux qui m' sont apparues
finalement assez utiles
parce que à la différence du Qatar,
l'Arabie Saoudite est partie sur des
postulats différents. Si tu veux, en
quelque sorte le Qatar, c'était le
nouveau riche. Tout à coup, ils ont été
bourrés de pognon. Ils ont vraiment
utilisé la diplomatie du carnet de
chèque. C'est-à-dire, il suffisait de
passer à l'ambassade du Qatar, de dire
que on était un vieil ami du Qatar,
qu'on avait un magnifique projet je ne
sais où. Et donc les gens reportaient
avec un chèque. Toute l'enquête de chez
Noima Brot, ça a été tracer l'argent. Et
c'est vrai que le Qatar avait pas une
ambition d'influencer le l'islam de
France. Ils étaient trop petits pour ça.
Bon, ils ont fait des petits trucs mais
enfin c'est pas la pointure de l'Arabie
Saoudite. Les Saoudiens, ils ont eu
l'intelligence de comprendre que il
n'avait aucun intellectuel exportable,
sauf des imames qu'on trouvait sur
internet et c'est pas ceux que tu mets
sur les plateaux de télé que il n'avaiit
pas de diaspora à l'étranger, donc il
pouvait pas avoir de groupe de pression
suffisant pour faire par exemple comme
les Algériens ou les Marocains une
espèce de organisation de l'opinion. Et
puis la dernière chose c'est que le
produit est invendable.
qui va prendre le défense de l'Arabie
Saoudite le pays le plus intolérant de
la planète le pays qui a le nombre de
décapitations par tête d'habitant si je
puis me permettre cette expression le
plus élevé que la planète c'està-dire
que les les saoudiens décapitent plus
que les Chinois. Bon donc le produit est
invendable. Ce qui fait qu'ils ont eu
l'intelligence de comprendre que il ne
fallait pas faire, il fallait faire
faire d'où leur contrat très vite avec
des sociétés de relation publique
par exemple
de relation publiqu de communication des
sociétés de lobby
lesquelles ?
Alors dès le 11 septembre enfin le
lendemain du 11 septembre il y a une
société qui s'appelle Corvis qui est
tout de suite approché les Saoudiens en
leur disant "Vous savez pas faire, on va
vous aider et cetera et cetera."
Ils avaient leur propre les Saoudiens
avaient leur propre système d'influence
sur le système politique. Évidemment, le
choc dans l'opinion publique était telle
que il y avait quand même du boulot.
Cette société a suivi l'Arabie Saoudite
pratiquement tout le temps
et même aujourd'hui en 2011, elle a été
rachetée par publicis et aujourd'hui
elle est responsable de la communication
de l'Arabie Saoudite à Bruxelles.
Pourquoi c'est si intéressant Bruxelles
? Parce que à Bruxelles, au Parlement
européen que tout le monde a l'habitude
de critiquer, il y a un observatoire des
lobby qui fait que tous les gens qui
veulent pénétrer au Parlement européen,
si c'était d'obist, ils doivent déposer
leur contrat et expliquer qui sont leurs
commanditaires. Donc quand tu regardes
sur ce site que tu vois quel est le
programme, le mandat qui est donné à
Corvis, tu te dis c'est formidable,
c'est améliorer l'image de l'Arabie
Saoudite, expliquer que ce n'est pas un
état qui finance le terrorisme, que
c'est un allié dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme et cetera et cetera. Donc tu
t'as dit c'est prodigieux, c'est un défi
pour un un communiquant d'arriver à voir
à communiquer là-dessus. Et donc ils ont
si tu veux aujourd'hui l'Arabie Saoudite
en peu de mots a des contrats avec les
cinq majors de la com mondiale,
c'est-à-dire les trois américaines WPP
Omnicom et le B schmeiler, j'arrive
jamais à le prononcer et puis les deux
françaises qui sont publicistes et avas.
Et donc aujourd'hui ils ont saturé le
marché de la com. L'originalité du
système saoudien, c'est qu'il ce ne sont
pas les grosses boîtes qu'il font. Les
grosses boîtes sous-traitent de façon à
qu'il y a une arborescence si tu veux
qui fait que on ne sait jamais, on peut
jamais dire non mais c'est l'Arabie
Saoudite qui a payé. Donc il y a des
petites boîtes françaises même parfois
tenu par des anciens membres de cabinets
du système français qui font des qui
organisent des voyages en Arabie
Saoudite et qui font dans lesquels les
gens s'y prêtent d'autant mieux que
effectivement leur interlocuteur n'est
pas l'ambassadeur d'Arabie Saoude.
Tous les gouvernements font ça.
Non, il y en a qui le font directement.
Quand tu es invité par une fondation
américaine, son mandat est clair, c'est
pour te faire comprendre le système
américain. Mais tu as des des entretiens
au Congrès, tu as des entretiens au
département d'État, tu as des entretiens
et tu as des entretiens avec des single
tank. En Arabie Saoudite, le mandat,
qu'est-ce que tu veux faire ? Tu veux
rencontrer qui ? La seule personne que
tu peux pas rencontrer rencontrer, c'est
les la hiérarchie religieuse.
C'est-à-dire ceux qui donnent cette
marque, cette empreinte à l'Arabie
Saoudite. Quand tu regardes les
documentaires sur l'Arabie Saoudite, un
journaliste qui parle là-bas, qu'est-ce
qu'il fait ? il va aller chercher le
rappeur saoudien et la femme qui
conduit. Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
C'est
celui qui a des tigres
et celui qui a des tigres. Ouais. Et
donc si tu au lieu de dire l'Arabie
Saoudite, c'est d'abord le grand imam
les descendants de Abdal Wahab, c'est
ceux-là qui font la morale, la police
religieuse, la réglementation sociale et
cetera. Donc tu te dis mais attends,
l'Arabie Saoudite c'est ça, c'est pas la
femme qui conduit, c'est pas le mec qui
a des tigres et c'est pas le type qui Tu
vois ce que je veux dire ? Donc la la
déviation médiatique, c'est
paradoxalement de ne pas s'attaquer au
cœur du sujet.
Comment ça se fait qu'on qu'on en soit
arrivé à à toute critique contre le
régime et c'est assimilé comme
c'est c'est assimilé contre comme une
critique contre l'islam ?
Alors, il y a trois trois aspects
différents, hein, dans le dans la
volonté des Saoudiens de maîtriser leur
communication.
La première cible, c'est les décideurs
occidentaux. C'estàdire quand un
décideur occidental va en Arabie
Saoudite, il revient toujours avec une
lettre d'intention. L'aide d'intention,
c'est regarder Vals, revenant d'Arabie
Saoudite 2 mois après les attentats
disant 10 milliards de contrats. Bon,
Trump il va un peu plus tard 110
milliards de contrats. Et tu te souviens
de cette image de Trump avec son panneau
expliquant qu'il avait sauvé un million
d'emploi aux États-Unis. Ce qui est
intéressant dans la lettre d'intention,
c'est quand tu fais le bilan après, il y
a pas obligatoirement contrat. Mais
l'homme politique revient dans son pays
en disant "Regardez avec moi ça avance."
Donc ceuxl tu sais qu' critiqueront pas.
La deuxième cible, c'est les hommes
d'affaires. Les hommes d'affaires.
Alors,
un projet pharaonique.
Alors, oui, on annonce un projet
pharaonique. Le dernier en date. C'est
donc cette cité qui s'appelle Neum qui
est une société, c'est un projet qui
devrait normalement coûter 500 milliards
de dollars dont il y a de quoi faire
rêver un certain nombre d'hommes
d'affaires quand même quand tu vas au
business forum de en Arabie Saoudite, tu
vas pas te lever en disant "Excusez-moi
mais je comprends je connais pas tous
les projets précédents que vous avez
présenté, les tax City diverses, il y en
a aucun qui a marché. Pourquoi celui-là
marché 2005, Abdallah Tech City en 2005
ensuite il y avait quoi ? King Abdouah
Economic City
voilà
port de l'armère rouge première ville
intelligente du monde à partir de rien
100 milliards en 2015 oui c'est ça donc
tu vois bien que si tu fais le bilan
d'épisodes précédents dans lesquels des
projets aussi pharaoniques ont été
proposés que tu fais passes 3 ans après
que tu t'aperçois soit que les immeubles
sont vides soit que la cité n'a jamais
vu le jour c'est que il y a bien quelque
chose qui est une mécanique de
communication à laquelle on ne croit que
parce qu'on sait que ce pays est
richissime.
Un des trucs intéressant par exemple sur
le projet qui est qui est proposé par
Mohamed Ben Salman, c'est l'idée de
privatiser 5 % de la grande société
pétrolière Ramco pour sortir le de
l'argent pour faire un fond
d'investissement qui deviendrait le plus
gros fond d'investissement du monde. Et
donc il y a de quoi faire rêver de faire
tourner les yeux de tous les ongles
pixous de la planète. Bon, simplement,
il n'arrive pas à privatiser 5 % de
Ramco pour une raison très simple, c'est
qu'il y a pas de comptabilité à Ramo. Si
tu fais le tour de nombre de princes, il
y a 10000 princes autour de la famille
royale, hein. Si tu fais le nombre le le
le relevé de de tous les mecs qui
émargent sur un Ramco, le type qui va
mettre 5 %, il aura jamais accès à la
comptabilité. Donc il y a une espèce de
contradiction dans les termes. Ça veut
pas dire que les entreprises perdent de
l'argent, mais ça veut dire que l'effet
de mirage est suffisamment convaincant
pour que personne ne critique. La
troisième cible qui est très importante
aussi, c'est les représentants de
l'islam à l'étranger. C'est-à-dire
il faut pas qu'il y ait des critiques
venant de pays musul de musulmans contre
l'Arabie Saoudite.
Et là, c'est la conjonction de deux
phénomènes. D'abord le fait que les
musulmans, les organisations musulmanes
à l'étranger ont toujours besoin
d'argent pour financer la construction
de mosquée et cetera. En France en
particulier, avec la loi 1905, il faut
qu'il trouve de l'argent. Donc les
financeurs sont essentiels des gens du
golf.
Et puis évidemment c'est la concurrence
Qatar Arabie Saoudite. Donc comme il
faut trouver de l'argent soit d'un côté
soit de l'autre, on se met on se
prononce pas sur le blocus. pas l'autre
question qui est extrêmement importante
aussi, c'est le Yémen et tu t'aperçois
qu'il y a jamais eu une critique
émanente du CFCM ni d'une autorité
religieuse française musulmane française
pour critiquer l'attitude de l'Arabie
Saoudite au Yémen. Pourquoi ? Parce que
les Saoudiens ont réussi à faire croire
que toute critique contre l'Arabie
Saoudite était une critique contre
l'Islam. C'est formidable. C'est comme à
l'époque de Moscou si tu veux. Si tu
critiquais Moscou, c'est que tu
critiquais le communisme. Tu te souviens
de ces procès fait agide revenant de
Est-ce qu'on peut faire le même
parallèle avec Israël ?
C'est aussi vrai parce que une des
originalités du comment dire de la vie
internationale aujourd'hui,
c'est que les pays sont toujours obligés
de tenir compte de leur diaspora. Bon et
leur diaspora a souvent un effet
d'influence sur leur propre sur le pays
d'accueil si tu veux. Alors, je peux pas
parler de la communauté juive comme une
communauté de diasporique, mais si tu
veux, ça veut dire que les gens savent
cette double appartenance à la fois à
leur pays d'accueil et à leur pays, si
tu veux, de euh comment dire,
d'appartenance culturelle. Et donc, il y
a l'idée de dire "Nous sommes le la
ligne de front, si tu veux, défenseur
d'Israël." Bon et tu t'aperçois
qu'effectivement dès que en France le
l'accusation d'antisémitisme vaut le
bas, dès qu'il y a un type qui critique,
c'est qu'il ne peut être antisémite. Et
de la même façon, dès que tu critiques
euh
des des tu t'exprimes des critiques sur
l'Arabie Saoudite, sur la politique
religieuse, que tu veux, tu es
immédiatement qualifié d'islamophobe.
Épisode, si tu veux personnel qui m'a
beaucoup fait plaisir. En 2014, je fais
un rapport pour une fondation privée sur
quelle politique de contreradicalisation
en France.
J'appelle le collectif contre
l'islamophobie en France. Je tombe sur
la l'attaché de presse, enfin la
porte-parole qui est une convertie et
puis je lui dis voilà, je voudrais vous
voir parce que je fais un travail sur la
radicalisation en France. Je voudrais
connaître votre point de vue sur le la
radicalisation que vous en pensez. La
fille me dit "Ah mais nous ça nous
concerne pas. Nous ne sommes concernés
que par les actes islamophobes. Je dis
attendez quand il y a une affaire ou
Nouche, vous avez bien évidemment des
communiqués, des choses pour vous
positionner après. Non non non, ça ne
nous intéresse pas. Nous seuls nous
intéressent les actes islamophobes. Je
dis c'est marrant quand je parle avec
vous, j'ai l'impression de parler avec
le CRIF. Alors je sais pas pourquoi il y
a eu un silence quand je lui ai dit ça
et puis après je lui ai dit mais le jour
où vous avez un musulman intégriste et
un juif radical qui se tape sur la
gueule comment on fait ? C'est de
l'antisémitisme ou c'est de
l'islamophobie ? Comment on fait ? C'est
le premier qui déclare qui a gagné et je
sais pas pourquoi il a raccroché.
Donc on est dans cette situation là.
C'est-à-dire, ils ont réussi à saturer,
si tu veux, le marché de la discussion
critique. Ce qui n'empêche pas un
certain nombre de français de culture
musulmane d'être extrêmement radical sur
l'analyse de l'influence du wahabisme.
Mais tu as quand même un un système, si
tu veux de communication qui est très
très efficace et en particulier les
élites musulmanes sont très embêtées, ne
serait-ce que dans le CSVM, tu as un
certain nombre de gens qui possèdent des
agences de voyage. Quand tu demandes des
visas pour des mecs qui veulent faire le
pèlerinage,
tu es obligé de t'adresser à un pays qui
doit te regarder dans mon œil. Si tu
commences à dire à prendre tes distance,
c'est ton c'est ta fille professionnelle
qui disparaît. Donc on est dans cette
situation là. Ce qui fait que dans
l'ensemble, ça aboutit à ce résultat
dont on parle. C'est-à-dire c'est un
pays protégé.
La diplomatie du chéquier de l'Arabie
Saoudite, ça représente combien de
milliards ? C'est très difficile à
chiffrer.
C'est très difficile à chiffrer parce
que il y a pas que les boîtes de
relation publique. Par exemple, aux
États-Unis qui est un système de lobbing
beaucoup plus développé, beaucoup plus
arborcent queon a en France, il y a par
exemple des fondations de l'argent. Par
exemple, le mandat euh donné à
l'ambassadeur d'Arabie Saoudite aux
États-Unis, c'est d'avoir l'accès direct
au bureau oval. Faut pas qu'il passe par
le département d'État. technique très
simple pour ça. Quand il y a une
campagne présidentielle, on finance les
deux camps. Comme ça, on est sûr qu'au
bout du compte, on aura le le contact
direct. Bon et donc aux États-Unis, tu
as ça, tu as le financement de de
fondation présidentielle, d'où
l'accusation de Trump contre contre
madame Clinton en disant "Regardez, elle
est financée par l'Arabie Saoudite." Il
y a le financement des chaires
universitaires, ce qui n'existe pas en
France. Et donc, il y a un système qui
est beaucoup plus intrusif et beaucoup
plus important aux États-Unis qu'en
France.
En France, comme les universités sont
encore dans un système étatique
classique, il y a très très peu, il y a
quasi, je n'ai trouvé qu'un seul exemple
de jumelage entre une université
saoudienne, une université française.
Donc, on n'est pas dans le même degré de
pénétration, mais par contre, on est
dans un état de faiblesse bien plus
grand que celui des États-Unis.
C'est-à-dire c'estù la raison de cette
espèce de mutisme de nos hommes
politiques et de nos hommes d'affaires
dès qu'on parle de l'Arabie Saoudite.
Et comment vous expliquez comment
tuexlique le fait que le Caps qui est la
cellule d'analyse et de prospective du K
d'Orsseil euh te charge euh prennent la
défense de de l'Arabie Saoudite parce
qu'ils sont véroulés dedans, parce
qu'ils ont fait leurs études dedans,
parce que papa il travaille dans le
coin, parce que il y en a un qui a
travaillé en Égypte, parce que quoi ?
Parce qu'ils ont des interconnexions,
ils doivent rendre des services ou c'est
tout simplement parce que tu te trompes
? Non, c'est le type qui a fait le
commentaire est un type qui était
observateur de la France à
l'organisation de la coopération
islamique à Riad. C'était effectivement
l'individu le plus objectif qu'on
pouvait trouver. Bon, donc il a fait une
note mais qui ensuite a été validée par
la hiérarchie. Alors, j'en ai parlé avec
des copains diplomates. Il m'a dit "Oui,
oui, on le connaitt, il fait des notes
totalement délirantes mais il est
statutairement diplomate." Donc, ils
l'ont mis au CAP probablement pour qu'il
arrête de de nuire ailleurs si tu veux.
Mais enfin, il est cette note était
d'autant plus ridicule que le canard
enchaîné en a fait une une brève. Et ça
le canard enchaîné quand c'est lu dans
les cabinets ministériel en général ça
provoque un séisme. Donc le jour où
c'est paru dans le canard enchaîné, j'ai
bu du petit la.
On est on est infiltré au sein de nos
institutions avec des relais d'influence
de l'Arabie Saoudite ?
Non, je crois que c'est pas c'est pas
une infiltration, c'est une espèce de
une combinaison de mutisme, on refuse
d'en parler.
C'est une espèce de de mélange de
défense des intérêts supérieurs de
l'État. C'est un gros client, nos
contrats d'armement, nos contrats de
TGV, nos contrats de machin et cetera.
Et puis l'opinion publique, les
Saoudiens s'en foutent, ils s'en
fichent. C'est pas leur sujet. Leur
sujet, c'est ici, on ne parle de
l'Arabie Saoudite que pour en dire du
bien. Et les médias dans une certaine
mesure jouent le jeu. C'est-à-dire que
je te cite l'exemple des 4 milliardaires
enlevés. Pourquoi n'a-t pas parlé des
quatre précédents ? parce qu'on se dit
"Mais attendez, l'Arabie Saoudite c'est
un pays rétrograde, content de l'être.
On c'est pas un sujet qu'on va traiter
tous les jours." Bon, je cite un exemple
dans ce rapport que m'a envoyé ma fille
des États-Unis qui est un site
d'opposants saoudien qui a relevé dans
New York Times sur 70 ans de New York
Times, les unes du journal à chaque fois
qu'il y avait un changement de roi en
Arabie Saoudite. Et ce qui est très
rigolo, c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'il y
avait un nouveau roi, la thématique de
l'article, c'était l'homme du
changement,
le nouveau royaume.
L'homme du changement. l'homme du
changement, c'est il y a pas de pays
plus immobile que celui-là, tu vois.
C'est exactement comme le moonw de
Michael Jackson, tu vois, ça donne
l'impression d'avancer, sauf que ça
recule. Mais
ils font des progrès,
non ? Si non, maintenant les femmes
peuvent conduire. Oui, mais tu te rends
compte qu'on en arrive à dire "Regardez,
il y a un progrès." Parce que dans le
seul pays du monde où les femmes
n'avaient pas le droit de conduire, tout
à coup, quand on nous l'annonce, on a
l'impression que c'est une
révolutionnicienne.
Quand il y a des femmes qui ont pris le
beau voulant, le volant pour dire "Mais
nous, on veut être libre et cetera,"
elles ont été arrêtées, emprisonnées,
torturées. Alors pourquoi d'un seul coup
on dit c'est la révolution, il va y
avoir une libéralisation et que les neuf
femmes qui ont été arrêtées qui
réclamaient plus, on les a foutu en to.
Il y a il y a encore des des dissidents
politiques dans leur jaô où ça s'est
arrêté parce que la France traite avec
eux. Est-ce que la France
aide aide les gens torturés en Arabie
Saoudite pour les faire sortir ? Est-ce
que la France paye des droits de l'homme
des Lumières ?
Non parce que par exemple
le comme politique publique d'abord le C
d'Orsé ne doit défendre que les citoyens
français. Ça c'est son comment dire la
la protection consulaire. Bon, il y a
pas pour le monde français qui sont
emprisonnés là-bas, mais enfin, ce qui
est intéressant, c'est les autres,
c'est-à-dire des gens qui ont été
condamnés de manière scandaleuse ou
alors ces femmes arrêtées et cetera.
Alors, sur les le cas le plus
symbolique, c'est le type qui s'appelle
R Bada qui est un type qui un blogueur
qui avait sur son blog dit queil
aimerait bien qu'il y ait un peu plus de
liberté de conscience et qu'on arrête de
traiter les autres religions comme si
elles étaient des religions diaboliques
et cetera.
Le type arrêté condamné à 10 ans de
prison et 1000 coups de fouet. 1000
coups de fouet qui reçoit par tranche de
50,
c'est-à-dire le quelque chose de
absolument scandaleux. Scandaleux. Bon,
aux États-Unis, tu as des campagnes de
défense de RF Badai. En France, tu as
quasiment rien. Alors, pourquoi ? J'en
ai parlé avec des gens des ONG. Alors,
pourquoi l'Arabie Saoudite et cetera ?
Par exemple, il y a une avocate
iranienne là qui est condamnée, qui est
une avocate défenseur des droits de
l'homme. Il y a 1 million de signatures
sur le site d'Amnestie Internationale.
Sur le site de R Badai, tu as 100000
signatures. Donc tu te dis tiens, c'est
étrange, pourtant le l'un et l'autre. Il
y a cette espèce de comment dire de
contrainte psychologique sur le thème
qu'on comprend pas. Alors, je pose la
question à un ancien président de la
Fédération internationale des droits de
l'homme. Je dis mais enfin c'est quand
même étonnant là, il y a un marché qui
est complet pour vous. vous avez tout ce
qu'il vous faut, la peine de mort tout
ça. Moi, il m'a dit c'est vrai, vous
avez raison. Et finalement, je crois que
comme nous avons des ressources
limitées, on a tellement l'impression
que ça ne sert à rien de faire quelque
chose sur l'Arabie Saoudite, qu'on
préfère affecter nos moyens sur des pays
où on pense que ça va avoir de l'effet.
Donc c'est paradoxal, ça aboutit au
résultats contraires de celui qu'on
pourrait avoir. Et alors pour en
terminer sur le cadre Badaoui, un jour
je fais un article dans le monde euh
justement pour expliquer ça, le
salafisme, wabisme, tout ce que c'était
tout pareil et je reçois un mail d'un
ancien d'un ambassadeur de France là-bas
que je connaissais qui me dit "Pierre,
tu exagères, ce pays se réforme, tu as
tort de le traiter comme ça et cetera."
Je dis "Tu fais un métier merveilleux."
On m'a raconté ça. Euh, il me dit "Mais
tu sais, la diplomatie discrète est plus
efficace que la diplomatie publique."
Bon, je dis "Ben écoute, tu peux
peut-être leur demander discrètement qu'
qu'ils abandonnent les 10 ans de prison
pour Badawioui parce que de toute façon,
il sera mort au bout de 1000 coups de
fouet." Donc, tu peux peut-être obtenir
ça. Bon, je sais pas pourquoi la
conversation s'est arrêtée. Donc, on est
avec ce genre de gens qui ont ce type de
rapport. C'est
celui qui qui ressemble un peu à gent du
jardin avec quelqu quelques kilos en
trop. Je
pas celà. Non, c'est pas ça. Non. Donc
c'est c'est pour dire que ce type est
intelligent, il connaît bien le sujet,
il connait bien la région et donc s'il
en arrive à tenir ce genre de propos,
c'est parce qu'il a complètement
intériorisé une partie de ce qu'on
pourrait appeler la raison d'état.
C'est-à-dire c'est un client qui ménage
quels que soient ses abus. On l'a bien
vu. Alors dans les faères Kachogi par
exemple, il y en a une très très belle.
Alexandre Adler, publiciste
international qui fait un article dans
le Figaro Vox pour dire moi d'après mes
sources de renseignement c'est pas les
Saoudien, c'est les Turcs. Erdogan, il
faut se méfier. Le lendemain Mohamed B
Salman reconnaît que c'est eux.
Il a il a il a un contrat avec les
l'Arabie Saoudite.
Je sais qu'il a essayé de débaucher un
copain à moi, c'est tout ce que je peux
te dire,
mais il reste que l'homme, tu vois, son
réseau d'influence.
Il y en a d'autres comme ça que vous
avez que tu as identifié ?
Non.
Non, ce qu'on peut se demander Jacquali.
Alors Jacques Atali, il est conseiller
économique de Mohamed Ben Salman. Tu vas
pas lui reprocher d'être conseiller
économique. C'est lui qui a conçu le
programme de la gauche. Donc peut-être
que demain il va faire le programme
commun pour l'Union pour le l'arb
Richard Atia.
Ben Atias lui il gagne du pognon avec le
Davos du DV désert. Donc il est
complètement dans sa dans son sa
fonction.
Il fait il fait du business légalement.
Ah bah oui, il fait du business
légalement. Encore une fois, c'est pas
obligatoirement de payer des gens pour
qu'ils soient à contreemploi. C'est
d'acheter des personnalités parisiennes
dont on sait que leur carnet d'adresse
permettra à certains moments d'ouvrir
certaines portes.
Ils sont pas achetés, ils travaillent.
Bah bien sûr. Oui, ils sont sous contrat
bien sûr. Mais tu il n'empêche que si tu
te choisis de prendre Jacquali, c'est
mieux que si tu prends l'observatoire
français des conjonctures économiques.
Rachid
Adati. Rachid Adati, c'est autre chose.
Là, c'est un personnalité qui
travaillait antérieurement pour le
Qatar. C'est ce que disent Shimal Bruno
et puis qui maintenant que le Qatar a
arrêté la diplomatie du carnet de
chèque, c'est bizarre, on la retrouve
plutôt du côté de l'Arabie Saoudite. Par
exemple, Rachid Adatiin, ni Rachid Adati
ni Michel Ali Marie n'ont jamais voté la
moindre résolution au Parlement européen
condamnant l'Arabie Saoudite. Donc je ne
peux que mettre les faits en rapport.
Moi, j'ai pas dit qu'elles étaient
payées pour ça. Peut-être qu'elles en
sont convaincu.
Bon, Nicolas Sarkozi,
bah Nicolas Sarkozi, lui en fait, il
fait il participe à des conférences où
il est très cher payé. Donc est-ce que
c'est un soutien ? Est-ce que c'est une
manière de
C'est c'est une dangereuse insinuation ?
Non. Pourquoi ? Il y est allé au moment
où il y avait l'affaire Cachogi, il y
avait le Davos du désert, des numéro 1
d'entreprise en particulier américaine
décident de ne pas y aller et notre
président ancien président de la
République il va. Bon, je je ne fais que
mettre en rapport le fait que l'éthique
aurait voulu que on surtout pour
quelqu'un qui n'est pas en charge, qui
n'est plus en charge, qui n'engage pas
la France, on aurait pu penser qu'il
pouvait s'en dispenser. Tu sais
aujourd'hui après l'affaire Kachogi,
il y a une seule boîte de relation
publique qui a rompu son contrat avec
l'Arabie Saoudite. Toutes les autres ont
continué, toutes. Tu vois ce que ça veut
dire ?
Quel qui a arrêté ?
Ah, c'est une boîte américaine. Bon,
j'ai pas le nom en tête exactement. Je
te je te le dirai si tu veux, mais c'est
pour dire que les liens contractuels
sont probablement tellement juteux que
même face à un scandale comme celui de
Kachogi, il y a aucune boîte qui renonce
à son contrat.
Est-ce que l'Arabie Saoudite continue sa
guerre avec l'Iran sur notre propre sol
? C'estàd est-ce qu' est-ce qu'il
finance des lobby anti-iraniens ? Est-ce
qu'il financent des choses comme ça ?
Oui, le en tout cas bon celui qui est le
plus facilement le plus facile à
identifier c'est le lobby des moujidines
du peuple. Mujidin du peuple sont un
parti d'opposants au régime des Mola qui
a fait une partie du chemin avec la
révolution au départ et puis qui pensait
qu'il mettrait facilement le vieux
Roméni dans leur poche. Bon ce qu'il
savaiit pas c'est que le personnage
était beaucoup plus astucieux et
beaucoup plus fort queux. Et donc en
fait, c'est eux qui ont été réprimés et
ils se sont ils sont partis à
l'étranger. Bon, ils sont partis à
l'étranger, ils sont venus en France et
depuis cette époque-là, les Iraniens
considèrent que c'est un un groupe
terroriste hein, puisque ils ont fait
des attentats sur le territoire iranien
et surtout ils ont fait la guerre avec
les Irakiens contre leur propre pays.
Donc c'est ce que nous on appelle des
collabos si tu veux dans l'époque de la
de l'occupion, on devait le comparer à
l'occupation.
Donc ces gens sont totalement
décrédibilisés en Iran, mais en France,
ils ont une espèce de savoir-faire que
les Saoudiens ne possèdent pas justement
pour avoir des compromissions inviter
des parlementaires et cetera. Alors, ils
ont chaque année une grande
manifestation à Villeint qui est un
grand raout dans lesquels,
juste pour l'anecdote, reportage de
France 24 sur une des séances à
Villepen, c'était il y a 4 5 ans et le
type de le journaliste de France 24 voit
des mecs qui sont dehors sur le gazon,
il va les interroger, c'était des jeunes
polonais.
Dit qu'est-ce que vous faites là ? Il
dit "Bon, nous on nous a proposé un
weekend à Paris pour remplir la salle."
Bon, on parle ni un mot de français, ni
un mot de de de person. Donc de toute
façon, on sait qu'après on va être
libéré, on va passer le weekend à Paris.
Bon, l'année suivante, c'était des mamas
africaines venues du 93 avec les enfants
qui couraient autour et cetera. Donc, tu
te dis, on fait un remplissage de salle
en dépensant de l'argent. Et point
d'orgue de tout ça, c'était il y a 2 3
ans, c'est l'ambassadeur d'Arabie
Saoudite qui à cette séance de ville
peinte annonce que Massou Rajavi est
mort depuis plusieurs années.
C'est-à-dire dans ce groupe dans lequel
madame Rajavi a pris la tête depuis
maintenant un certain nombre d'années
qui n'a jamais dit qu'est-ce qu'il était
arrivé au père fondateur, c'est
l'ambassadeur d'Arabie Saoudite qui
probablement n'était pas au courant de
cette ligne de communication qui a mangé
le morceau. Et donc tu te dis dans ce
cas-là effectivement les Saoudiens
soutiennent ce mouvement d'opposition.
Il n'a aucune crédibilité mais ils le
soutiennent. Donc on est sur des il y a
des on est un terrain de jeu si tu veux
pour le cela dit, il y a pas de beaucoup
de crédit pour on est un terrain de jeu.
Est-ce que tu as des des retours de nos
services de renseignement intérieur ?
Est-ce que il y a une une modélisation ?
Est-ce que il y a du mapping de de ces
relais extérieurs ? Parce que on fait
tout un scandale sur les Russes, sur les
Américains et ainsi de suite. Mais
est-ce que on cartographie le le autres
réseaux d'influence ?
Non, c'est une des questions que je me
suis posé parce que j'en ai parlé avec
Malb Bruno justement en disant mais
tiens, on devrait faire un truc ensemble
sur la France de lobby de lobby
internationale évidemment pas de
et c'est vrai que
ce ceuxl en tout cas les pays du golf
sont ceux qui portaient avec le plus
gros handicap parce que plein de pognons
mais en même temps invendable c'est
c'est là que si tu veux les sociétés de
relation publique ont probablement les
marchés les plus intéressants. dans des
pays comme les États-Unis, ils ont pas
besoin de boîte de relation publique, il
font faire parce que c'est le
département d'État qui va inviter. C'est
des par exemple, il y a un programme qui
s'appelle le German Marshall Fond qui
est un une fondation qui a été créée
avec de l'argent qui resté du plan
Marchal et qui est dédié chaque année à
inviter des personnalités étrangères,
des tu sais un peu comme les programmes
du CAP, les programmes des personnalités
d'avenir. Donc ceux-là n'ont pas besoin.
Tu vas pas faire du lobby britannique en
France. Donc là, on est sur des pays qui
ont besoin d'une d'un savoir-faire.
Bon, l'islam en France, ça donne quoi ?
Ça ça continue de financer
la le rapport Elkarcoui, ça donne quoi ?
L'islam français est-il possible ?
Ambassadeur Saoudien déclare : "Au
total, nous avons versé 3,7 millions
d'euros, soit en moyenne 7500 € par an,
14 imams, quelques 2200 qui officient en
France."
Oui, le rapport Alkara moi en tout cas
me fait grand plaisir puisque justement
il ne cesse de parler de la wabisation
de l'islam de France. Donc mon camarade
du Kedors je pense l'a lu celui qui a
critiqué mon bouquin parce qu'il
s'aperçoit que c'est ma thèse qui
aujourd'hui triomphe partout.
C'est-à-dire oui, on sait que le
salafisme est d'origine whabite
et donc on sait que c'était l'Arabie
Saoudite en tout cas qui a diffusé
l'idéologie. La contradiction de
l'Arabie Saoudite, c'est que on sait
très bien qu'ils ont besoin des
mécréants quand ça va mal. Et quand ils
appellent les mécréants pour les
défendre, c'est leur hiérarchie
religieuse qui commence à râer. Scénario
91, quand Saddam Hussein envahit le Kit,
à ce moment-là, tous les Saoudiens
serrent les fèches, les princes
saoudiens. Et donc, on va faire appel
aux Américains et aux autres pour venir
défendre le
les coufars.
Alors, on va faire appel on va appeler
les les coufars pour venir défendre la
terre de l'Islam.
le donc il y a cette contradiction,
c'est-à-dire qu'à chaque fois il faut
sau pour sauver la dynastie, il faut
marcher sur la tête des religieux. Mais
les religieux en général se vengent
après. Par exemple, après la crise de
91, donc après le l'arrivée des troupes
américaines,
ils ont fermé tous les cinémas de Riad.
Pourquoi faire du cinéma dans un pays
qui est un un islam intégriste, le
cinéma, il a pas de raison d'être, c'est
une représentation humaine. Donc, ils
ont fermé tous les cinémas. tu vas tu
vas me dire quel est le rapport entre
l'un et l'autre si ce n'est le fait
qu'il fallait donner à la hiérarchie
religieuse un contrôle supplémentaire
sur la société saoudienne. Et donc les
résistances à l'intérieur de la société
saoudienne font que la dynastie peut
être menacée et d'ailleurs comme il y a
eu des attentats contre les compagnes
américains, les Américains sont
déplacés, ils sont allés s'installer à
DOA où se trouve maintenant la base
américaine qui contrôle le golfe. Donc
si tu veux, les les Saoudiens savent
très bien la dynastie sait très bien que
il faut pas se fâcher avec les
occidentaux parce qu'on peut en avoir
besoin. D'où une ligne très prudente
dans le cas de la France, financement
effectivement d'une douzaine de
mosquées, ce qui est pas énorme.
financement de 14 imames mais une
machine qui continue à tourner qui
s'appelle l'université islamique de
Médine qui est l'espèce d'université
Lumumba comme l'avait fait les
communistes si tu veux dans les années
50 c'est-à-dire une université dans
laquelle on forme des cadres qui vont
être des cadres salafistes qui ont
instruction de repartir ensuite dans
leur pays. Ils peuvent pas demander la
nationalité saoudienne. Par exemple,
aujourd'hui au Mali où les troupes
françaises se battent pour défendre le
pays contre les sal djihadistes, le
représentant de l'islam malien est un
ancien de l'université de Médine,
Mohamed Diko, le type qui a refusé de
condamner l'attentat contre le Radison
Blue dans lequel sont morts des
Français. Donc on se dit "Mais attends,
on est complètement schizophrène."
C'est-à-dire qu'on on va faire semblant
de se battre contre des gens qui en même
temps te diffusent un peu partout sur la
planète leur idéologie.
On fait quoi ? On les envahit
l'Arabie Saoudite.
Non, je crois que si tu veux, il faut
être d'abord extrêmement clair avec eux
puis ensuite il y a des moments il faut
faire preuve de courage. Quand on la
Merkel rond le le contrat d'armement
avec l'Arabie Saoudite, on m'explique
que l'Allemagne vend moins que nous.
C'est pas vrai. L'Allemagne certaines
années a vendu plus que nous d'armement,
plus d'armement que nous, y compris dans
les pays du golfe. Donc je vois pas
pourquoi tout à coup on nous sort cet
argument en nous disant "Non, non, mais
c'est impossible pour le cas de la
France. C'est un acte de fa courage
politique.
Nos propres services euh censé propager
la parole de la France, censé aller nous
chercher des contrats. Est-ce qu' ils
ont une éthique où la raison d'État
surpasse toute l'éthique ? Ben, tu sais,
moi j'ai j'ai travaillé à l'exportation
d'armement justement en quittant la
délégation aux affaires stratégiques
parce que je me suis dit bon c'est
tellement facile de l'extérieur de
critiquer, je veux savoir commencer de
l'intérieur. Bon et donc j'ai pris un
poste pour m'occuper de la politique
d'exportation à l'intérieur de la
délégation générale pour l'armement
qui a vocation non seulement à
développer des programmes français mais
en plus qui a une branche internationale
pour vendre de l'armement français à
l'étranger. Et je me suis rendu compte
que nous, notre caractéristique dans
notre formation, dans notre philosophie,
on apprend à bien faire ce qu'on nous
demande de faire. Mais quand tu vends
des armements, qu'est-ce que c'est bien
faire ? C'est vendre plus ou c'est
vendre mieux ? Tu comprends que ce soit
une contradiction continue ? Parce que
tu te dis par exemple, je vais vendre
des sous-marins au Pakistan. Le Pakistan
est un pays dans lequel la moitié du
temps d'indépendance a été occupé par un
pouvoir militaire. Mais tu dis en même
temps les sous-marins, c'est pas avec ça
que tu fais un coup d'état. On
a pas une petite affaire avec le
Pakistan, les sous-marins Alors
justement si tu fais le parallèle
l'affaire de des commissions sur les
contrats d'ement si tu veux c'est un
autre sujet parce ça ne concerne pas que
le Pakistan mais c'est juste pour te
dire que tu peux toujours trouver un
argumentaire qui va te dire non mais je
vends des armes qui ne servent pas
pendant l'Arabie Saoudite on vendait des
armes à l'Arabie Saoudite qui a été
longtemps notre meilleur client et
encore aujourd'hui en moyenne lycée mais
parce que les Saoudiens s'en servaient
pas ils achetaient des garanties de
sécurité ils achetaient des
anxiolitiques.
Donc on pouvait vendre d'autant plus
qu'on savait que les Saoudiens
n'utilisaient pas ces armes. Ce qui nous
pose problème maintenant, c'est le fait
qu'il les utilisent au Li Yémen. Là
maintenant on est face pour se protéger
voyons.
Oui. Surtout les canons César puisqu'il
les garde du bon côté de la frontière et
que ça a une une trajectoire d'environ
une quarantaine de kilomètres.
C'est-à-dire que il y a une ONG de
dénonciation de la politique française
d'armement qui explique qu'il y a à peu
près 500000 personnes qui sont sous le
champ de des canons César qui sont du
côté défensif de la frontière.
Quand il y a il y a les dockers qui
bloquent l'approvisionnement de de des
bateaux qui sont censés fournir ensuite
les les munitions pour les canon César,
les dockers français, c'est bien, c'est
pas bien, c'est à l'état de le faire.
Est-ce que est-ce que les doqueurs se
substituent maintenant à l'état et à
l'éthique de notre état ?
Ben là en l'espèce, la chose a été
effectivement assez remarquable puisque
ils ont refusé de charger. On était en
pleine affaire Cachogi, donc on était
dans le paroxisme de d'oligini quoi.
Donc ils ont refusé de de laisser le
bateau rentrer. Finalement, il est parti
en Espagne et il a embarqué en Espagne
les choses. Je crois que c'était des
munitions qui venaient chercher. Bon
donc c'est vrai que si on n pas une
position européenne minimum commune sur
l'Arabie Saoudite, on aura pas de moyen
de pression. Mais quand il y a un pays,
par exemple, j'ai un exemple qui est
très intéressant. Le Canada euh il y a à
peu près 1 an, un an et demi a pris la
défense des neuf femmes qui avaient été
emprisonnées, les neuf femmes qui
avaient demandé à ne plus avoir de
tuteur à pouvoir conduire et cetera. Le
Canada a critiqué le fait que ces femmes
avaient été menacées sexuellement,
peut-être violé, en tout cas torturé.
Bon, les Saoudiens ont fait ni une ni
deux, ils ont coupé les relations
diplomatiques avec le Canada. Aucun état
occidental ne s'est solidarisé avec le
Canada. Aucun.
Ça veut dire qu'on est dans un espèce de
jeu de menteur formidable et avec
toujours le même résonnance. Si c'est
pas nous qui vendons, c'est les autres
qui vendent. Mais est-ce que ça nous
dédoine pour autant ?
Je tiens à dire un point d'information.
Comme nous n'avons jamais vendu un avion
de combat, il ne faut pas accuser
d'assaut sur l'Arabie Saoudite. Ce n'est
pas d'assaut, c'est tous les autres.
C'est qui les autres ? Oh ben c'est à l'
c'est ADS et toutes ces entreprises
c'est DCN c'est tout ça mais le il y a
de toute façon encore une fois ce sont
des marchés autultiplicateurs très
importants donc c'est des marchés sur
lesquels pour te donner un exemple
British Aerospace était quasiment en
faillite il y a une vingtaine d'années
ils ont signé à l'époque où on pensait
pensait vendre des mirages de 1000 à
l'Arabie Saoudite ils ont vendu des
tornados avion européens ça a
complètement remplumé Bish aospace qui
était sur le point de déposer le bilan
donc ça te donne une idée de ce que
c'est qu'un contrat saoudien. Bon et
donc tu vas expliquer à des Français
queils vont perdre leur boulot parce
qu'on veut pas vendre au des armes à
l'Arabie Saoudite qui ne s'en servaient
pas. Le problème il se pose maintenant
qu'il les utilise.
Le lobby de l'armement en France c'est
que ça représente combien d'emplois ?
C'est à peu près 100 à 120000 emplois.
Ça dépend si on prend les emplois
directs ou les emplois induits parce
qu'il y a toujours effectivement des
sous-traitants de
on atteint je crois 150000 quand même
avec la avec la sous-traitance. C'est un
c'est un marché important hein.
Et ça représente combien de milliards ?
Ça dépend si on prend le le chiffre
d'exportation, pas le chiffre
d'affaires. Le chiffre d'affaires, il y
a évidemment tous les armements français
qu'on achète et cetera. En exportation,
je crois qu'on fait quelque chose comme
9 à 10 milliards d'eur d'euros de
d'exportation nette.
La France peut pas s'en passer.
Il ils sont protégés judiciairement
parlant.
Alors, le cas du sous-marin pakistanais
est intéressant parce que
il y a donc une enquête faite par le à
la fois par le Section antiterroriste et
en même temps par le GAFI parce que
qui est le l'organisme de lutte contre
le financement international du
terrorisme.
Comment il passe-il l'affaire ? Affaire
est partie du fait que euh il y a eu un
attentat contre des ingénieurs de la
direction des constructions navales à
Karashi et donc les familles de ces
ingénieurs ont déposé plainte en disant
c'est un attentat terroriste. Cet
attentat a été fait parce que on n'a pas
payé les commissions au d au au
Pakistanais. Donc c'est une vengeance
contre la France. Bon donc ça a
déclenché la machine judiciaire avec une
enquête criminelle, une enquête de la
corruption et cetera et cetera.
Première remarque simultanément en signe
avec l'Arabie Saoudite, les contrats
pour deux frégates Sawari Sa 2 qui ont
exactement les mêmes taux de corruption
mais sur lesquels on n jamais ouvert une
instruction. On a expliqué qu'il y avait
pas eu d'attentat donc on ne pouvait pas
être saisi, il y avait pas eu de plainte
et cetera et cetera. Donc tu vois déjà
la différence de traitement. Voilà euh
le
Jean-Louis Brugier, il avait fait du bon
boulot.
Bah, il avait fait de toute façon ce
qu'il pouvait faire, c'est-à-dire qu'il
est enfermé dans un compte de procédure
pénale. Il va pas ouvrir à lui seul un
dossier sur l'Arabie Saoudite. Surtout
que les Saoudiens détestent se retrouver
en position où tout à coup, on va leur
dire qu' qu'il financent ici, queils
sont corrompus et cetera et cetera.
Peut-on accuser d'ailleurs de corruption
des dirigeants d'un pays dans lequel il
y a pas de loi contre la corruption
puisque il y a pas de distinction entre
l'argent public et l'argent du prince.
Donc on peut être juriste, mais enfin
expliquer à travers la charia que c'est
de la corruption, c'est compliqué quoi.
Médiatiquement parlant, bon on a vu, ils
sont protégés.
Alors, médiatiquement par parlant,
l'affaire Kachogi est quand même un
tournant hein. C'est-à-dire que ça a
tellement scandalisé l'ensemble de la
planète puis le le feuilleton que les
les Turcs ont parfaitement géré si tu
veux pour en sortant des informations au
fur et à mesure, on fait qu'on est
arrivé quand même à un certain moment de
paroxisme où le procès du système
saoudien est quand même apparu. Bon,
mais ce qui est très intéressant, c'est
que des Turcs ont demandé à extrader que
l'Arabie Saoudite extrade les types du
commando dont ils avaient les noms et
cetera et cetera. L'Arabie Saoudite a
dit non, c'est nous qui les qui les
jugerons chez nous. Comme nous
d'ailleurs on dit on va pas extrader nos
propres ressortissants, on va les juger
chez nous. Et donc le ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'un des proches
collaborateurs de Mohamed Ben Salman qui
s'appelle Alcatani qui est un
francophone d'ailleurs qui était invité
régulièrement dans des colloques en
France. il a fait des coloques à l'école
militaire était un des dirigeants de
cette ce groupe de d'assassins. Bon
celui-là, on a dit alors cet homme
c'était celui c'était le la comment dire
le le mauvais ange le mauvais ange
auprès de Mohamed Salman. C'est-à-dire
qu'il avait créé une équipe de blogueurs
si tu veux qui était chargé de
poursuivre tous les opposants qu'il
trouvaient sur internet, de les
dénoncer, de les menacer et cetera. Donc
c'est un personnage très admirable si tu
veux qui mérite qui gagne à être connu.
Ils ont demandé son extradition
puisqu'il était chef du commando et les
Saoudien ont refusé. Donc on a dit ben
il va être condamné à mort. Non, il fait
pas partie de la liste des condamnés à
mort.
il est il est même probablement
retrouver ses fonctions. Donc on est
effectivement sur quelque chose où on aa
comment dire le futur de notre relation
avec l'Arabie Saoudite se jugera sur la
façon dont sera géré la suite de
l'affaire Kashogi. Aux États-Unis ça
continue à bouillonner mais ici en
France qui s'intéresse à Kashogi ?
Est-ce que vous avez identifié des
livres de complaisance envers l'Arabie
Saoudite ? Non, c'est-à-dire que c'est
pas c'est pas sous la enfin, il y a un
livre qui est quand même assez fascinant
qui s'appelle l'Arabie Saoudite, ce pays
méconnu. Donc celui-là, on a
l'impression qu'effectivement c'est le
dépliant touristique, quoi. Mais enfin,
je vous conseille pas d'aller faire
C'est qui ?
C'est une fille qui s'appelle SW de
Sabb, si je me souviens bien.
Mais dans le contrat, s'est pas très
bien passé parce que finalement, elle a
rompu avec l'Arabie Saoudite. Donc quand
on a un truc qui sur un pays qui
l'Arabie Saoudite, on dit ce pays
méconnu, ça va l'impression qu'il va y
avoir un flot de touristes qui vont
débarquer. Mais enfin bon, je conseille
pas.
Il y a d'autres livres qui sont plus
prudents. Par exemple, il y a un livre
qui s'appelle
l'Arabie Saoudite en sans question qui
est un livre donc manuel scolaire sur
l'Arabie Saoudite. Bon, le problème
c'est que la question 101, c'est
qu'est-ce que sont devenus les quatre
mecs qui ont été enlevés avant Cachogi,
ça n'a pas été traité. La question 102,
c'est est-ce qu'il y a des opposants à
l'étranger ? Celui-là, celle-là non plus
n'a pas été. Donc c'est un manuel
d'instruction civique sur l'Arabie
Saoudite.
Christine Ok, elle a fait des bouquins
sur l'Arabie Saoudite.
Alors ChristineOren, j'en ai parlé avec
son éditeur et effectivement
moi je j'ai été assistée après la
présentation de son bouquin. Ils avaient
assisté pour que je vienne et cetera.
Bref, donc elle l'a fait avec
intelligence, c'est-à-dire son bouquin
se lit très bien. Elle fait une espèce
de pondération entre les casseroles et
puis les qualités du personnage. Mais si
tu veux quand on fait un livre une
biographie sur un personnage aussi
contesté que celui-là, il faut prendre
position. Tu peux pas en faire une
espèce de mina en disant moi. Moi, j'ai
cru qu'elle n'avait jamais rencontré
Mohamed Ben Salman. En tout cas, elle ne
dit jamais dans son bouquin qu'elle l'a
rencontré. Donc, l'a-t-elle rencontré ou
pas ? Mais enfin, écrire une biographie
sur un mec vivant aussi contesté que
celui-là, sans dire que tu l'as
rencontré puis qu'il t'a fait des
confidences,
ça reste, ça laisse la question à
suspend.
En terme, en terme de de des actions
thématiques ciblées, ils font quoi ? Ils
font des concerts ? Ils font des dessins
animés, ils font des voyages
touristiques ? Non, je crois que les
boîtes de relation publique leuront dit
effectivement que le produit est
invendable. C'estàd on peut pas vendre
l'Arabie Saoudite, c'est pas possible.
Donc le seule manière, c'est de se
différencier en faisant des actions
thématiques, c'est-à-dire
la Reine des Neiges voilées.
Bah ouais, on va faire la Reine des
Neiges Voilées. On va faire un grand
spectacle
dans sur le site d'Aloula qui est un
site Nabaté dans le nord de l'Arabie
Saoudite. On va faire venir une vedette
américaine et cetera et cetera. leur
grande, il y a un grand projet de cité
du tourisme, c'est-à-dire que ils
veulent faire un espèce de Disneyland en
Arabie Saoudite. Alors, il y a un un
commentateur américain qui a eu une
phrase que je trouve très
extraordinaire. Il a dit
"C'est Ralam ou c'est pas Ralam ?"
Non, mais alors justement, il dit il
disnefies de Saudi Arabia. C'est-à-dire
qu'en fait, il transforme l'Arabie
Saoudite en un monde de Disney. Parce
que tu imagines bien que la seule chose
qui puisse culturellement passer en
Arabie Saoudite sous le contrôle des
religieux, c'est le les personnages de
Disney. Mais il y a quand même un imam
saoudien qui a dit que les souris,
notamment Mickey Mouse, c'était un
personnage diabolique parce que comme le
prophète a dit qu'il fallait exterminer
les souris et comme les Américains ont
réussi à glorifier un Mickey Mouse,
c'est que Mickey Mouse c'était un
personnage diabolique. Donc il fallait
interdire les Mickey Mouse. Donc tu
vois, il y a une créativité quand même
du côté de l'Arabie Saoudite qu'on a
tort de négliger. C'est capable ces gens
sont Tu sais ce que disait Einstein, il
disait il y a deux choses qui donne une
idée de l'infini, c'est l'univers et la
connerie humaine. Mais pour l'univers,
on n'est pas sûr.
Quand on quand on est lobbyiste pour
l'Arabie Saoudite,
on a une conscience, on fait comment ?
On s'arrange avec sa conscience
ou ou on fait simplement lobbyiste, on
défend les intérêts de son client ? Bah
si on est lobbyiste, il vaut mieux pas
avoir trop de problèmes de conscience
quand même parce que plus l'achat de
tâche est difficile, plus le contrat est
juteux.
C'est un truisme de dire ça. Donc
effectivement aujourd'hui la boîte qui
est la plus comment dire qui a eu le
plus de contrat avec l'Arabie Saoudite à
travers ces différentes filiales, c'est
Publicis. Bon publicist à travers
justement le rachat de cette boîte
Corvis dont je parlais tout à l'heure
qui est donc mandaté sur le qui est
mandaté sur le Bruxelles et cetera et
cetera et qui continue à travailler en
arab aux États-Unis sur pour l'Arabie
Saoudite. Donc on a en France une des
boîtes qui est qui a les plus gros
contrats avec l'Arabie Saoudite. Cette
boîte est partiellement la propriété de
madame Badinter. Madame Badinter qui
défend les femmes partout dans le monde
sauf en Arabie Saoudite. Et donc quand
elle est interpellée par des
journalistes qui lui disent "Mais enfin
est-ce que ça vous pose des questions de
conscience" ? Elle dit "Non mais de
toute façon, je n'irai jamais, je ne
porterai jamais le voile puisque je
n'irai jamais en Arabie Saoudite." Donc
ma question est réglée. Donc tu vois
bien qu'on peut s'arranger avec sa
conscience.
Là là par rapport à nous français, nous
notre ministère des affaires étrangères,
est-ce que tu penses un jour qu'on qu'on
arrivera à interviewer soit le ministre
des affaires étrangères, soit son
porte-parole ? À chaque fois qu'on
essaie de les avoir, ils disparaissent,
ils se volatilisent ou ils nous
racontent un peu n'importe quoi pour que
on évite de de les attraper. Est-ce que
Est-ce que tu les vois pouvoir affronter
en direct des questions de la communauté
sans filtre ou est-ce qu'ils sont
vraiment pied et point lié que ils sont
dans un système inextricable ? Ils ont
pris le rôle d'ambassadeur ou ils ont
pris le rôle de travailler auquet d'or
uniquement pour brillant société quand
il côtoi le bourgeois
ou pour viser des postes privés ensuite
? Est-ce que c'est simplement des des
passeurs de sommeil dans Est-ce que
est-ce que c'est c'est toujours le
dormeur du qued d'ors qui qui vit là-bas
? Ils attendent simplement que leur
charges se finisse pour pouvoir
bénéficier des fruits de la République ?
Écoute, il y a deux il y a deux
questions. Il y a le comment dire la
sociologie du K d'Orset et puis il y a
l'homme politique qui va devenir
ministre et avec les responsabilités de
porter la communication officielle. Bon,
le grosso modo, notre tradition
diplomatique a été une bonne fois pour
impliquée par de comment dire imprégné,
défini par de Gaul si tu veux. Et depuis
cette époque là, on répète le discours
golien, la France indépendante, machin,
tout ce que tu veux voir. Mais en même
temps, cette diplomatie là est
contredite par un certain nombre de
choses, si tu veux qui sont très qui
sont très évidentes. Bon, il y a eu
l'affaire du Rwanda qui ressort et
cetera.
Donc les gens du qued d'oré, c'est ce
qui m'a été confirmé par un certain
nombre de de diplomates,
ils ont appris à l'ouvrier. C'est-à-dire
le ministre donne ses instructions,
ensuite il mettent en forme. Donc il
faut accepter le fait que tu devras être
en charge d'une politique que tu
désapprouves parce que tu es au contact
d'un pays dont tu sais que sa ligne
n'est pas du tout celle qu'on va essayer
de faire respecter dans la ligne
officielle. Et donc les diplômates d'une
certaine manière se retrouvent à devoir
tout au long de leur vie accepter de
tenir un propos qui n'est pas
obligatoirement leur opinion
personnelle. Et ça c'est dans leur
statut. C'est comme les policiers qui
sont pas toujours d'accord de taper sur
des manifestants mais en fait ils sont
policiers.
Là où effectivement la chose est plus
facile ou plus difficile à vivre, c'est
quand tu as des responsabilités
politiques. Puisque quand tu as des
responsabilités politiques, à un moment,
il faut que tu prononces toi-même si tu
veux ce que va être la ligne de ta. Et
donc on l'a vu que on est toujours
capable, si tu veux, de définir une
ligne qui peut-être totalement décalée
par rapport à la réalité parce que on
est en charge d'un gouvernement, il y a
une solidarité gouvernementale, donc le
ministre des affaires étrangères va
accepter de tenir quelque chose qui qui
représenterait soi-disant les intérêts
supérieurs du pays. Et donc sur l'Arabie
Saoudite, on va expliquer que
déclaration présidentielle Kachogi n'a
rien à voir avec le Yémen.
Revenons, revenons un peu à la région.
L'Iran euh des pétroliers qui se font
euh miner ou censés se faire miner ou
aurait été miné par le l'Iran.
J'ai pas de j'ai pas d'information. Moi,
j'ai un alibi, j'étais pas là-bas. Donc
si tu veux, c'est tout ce que je peux
dire. On est dans une situation où on a
comment dire, c'est un choc de Titan,
c'est les plus menteurs. Tu sais pas
lequel est le plus menteurs, si c'est
Trump, si c'est
les les Iraniens ou si c'est les
Saoudiens.
Menteur en terme de false flag. Ah oui
oui bien sûr bien sûr. En terme de
construction en terme de construction
d'une d'un mensonge. Oui bien sûr.
Les si tu veux les il y a des il y a des
exemples dans l'histoire de FS flag.
Euh bah oui, il y en a plein. Enfin je
veux dire nous on part toujours du
postulat qu'une démocratie est pacifiste
et qu' une dictature est est béliciste
quand même. On a quand on a un
personnage Trump qui succède à George
Bouche qui a ou même rappelle-toi
l'affaire du poama.
Attends, non mais reprends quelques
exemples historiques avérés. L'affaire
du Peblot pour déclencher la guerre du
Vietnam, tu te souviens le bateau espion
qui est raisonné par vietnamien et prof
ça commence la campagne de bombardement.
Bon, on savait très bien que c un bateau
espion et donc par la suite on sait que
ça a été une provocation voulue pour
déclencher la guerre du Vietnam. Là, le
déclenchement de la guerre en Irak,
c'est un mensonge et honté. Moi, je me
souviens j'avoir entendu Coline Powell
dans un dans un colloque dans le golf
justement. Il expliquait qu'il s'était
fait manipuler. Mais il s'était fait
manipuler. Si le le chef du département
d'État, il se fait manipuler, on se dit
"Mais comment fonctionne
l'administration américaine ?" Et là
aujourd'hui, on est avec un type qui à
la limite n'a même plus besoin de ses
services pour inventer des trucs, c'est
Trump. Donc on a comment dire encore une
fois un champion du monde si tu veux qui
est à la tête d'une des plus grandes
démocraties du monde. Du côté des
Iraniens, ben les Iraniens, c'est eux
qui ont inventé la Takya. C'est-à-dire,
tu sais que ce droit religieux de mentir
a été inventé parce que les chiites
étaient minoritaires et que pour pouvoir
défendre leur propre conception de
l'islam, on acceptait que religieusement
ce qu'il dirait pour se défendre n'était
pas du mensonge. Donc aujourd'hui ça
s'est répandu partout puisque tout le
monde te le ressort même pour parler des
salafistes. Et donc et en face de ça, tu
as l'Arabie Saoudite qui est le pays le
plus intolérant de la planète, le plus
celui qui ne tolère aucune autre
religion, qui est capable d'ouvrir à
Vienne un centre sur le dialogue des
cultures. quand même pas mal quand même.
Tu sais pas, je sais pas si avec qui tu
peux parler en Arabie Saoudite et donc
tu as une espèce d'hypocrisie générale
sur la région et donc tu peux très bien
avoir n'importe lequel de ces individus
qui décident n'importe comment de faire
la provocation qui va crper la
situation. Le seul pays qui se tient la
tête hors de l'eau dans cette région,
c'est Aman. C'est le seul qui s'est tenu
à l'écart de toutes les conflits. C'est
le seul qui disent "Nous, on a rien à
voir avec tout ça" et ils refusent. Ils
ont d'excellentes relations avec les
rangs, ils ont d'excellentes relations
avec l'Arabie Saoudite. Enfin, ils
emmerdent tout le monde puisqu'ils ont
des relations des relations excellentes
avec tout le monde.
Est-ce que la France doit couper ses
relations avec l'Arabie Saoudite ?
relations avec l'Iran ?
Non, je pense que la France a un rôle à
jouer aujourd'hui pour empêcher le
scénario de la guerre parce que le
scénario de la guerre, il peut demain
éclater encore une fois parce qu'on va
expliquer
quelle forme
pardon
sous quelle forme ?
Ben encore une fois la provocation est
une provocation qui peut prendre
n'importe quelle forme. Par exemple,
l'histoire du drone qui a été abattu.
On va dire il était sur les eaux
internationales. L'autre il dit non, il
était dans nos eaux territoriales.
Tu sais que il y a tu peux plaider la
cause devant n'importe quelle cour de
justice. Les eaux territoriales c'est
pas coloré hein. Tu sais pas à quel
moment tu rentres dans les eaux
territoriales. Donc on sait très bien
qu'une un événement comme celui-là peut
déclencher une rétorsion, la rétorsion
déclenchant et cetera. Et puis surtout
dans la région, le moindre scénario de
conflit bloque le le golf puisque c'est
quand même le le D3 d'Ormouse. Et donc
on sait que n'importe quelle guerre
n'aboutirait pas aurait obligatoirement
des effets dans l'ensemble de la
planète. Le pétrole du golf s'en va pour
l'essentiel vers l'Asie. Donc tous les
pays d'Asie sont concernés. Nous on va
être obligé de faire jouer la solidarité
atlantique. Et donc rappelle-toi quand
il y a eu la guerre en Irak, la moitié
de l'Europe a suivi Trump a suivi Bush.
Donc on est dans une situation qui est
particulièrement explosive. Si la France
a un rôle joué à mon sens c'est
d'essayer de dénoncer cette politique de
du conflit. Le conflit, il a été créé
artificiellement par Bush par Trump. Il
a décidé en arrivant de dénoncer
l'accord nucléaire qui a été signé par
cinq autres pays. Ça veut dire tous les
autres sont des abrutis. Moi Trump, je
vais vous expliquer ce qu'il faut faire.
Il met un embargot le plus dur qu'il
soit et on a vu ce que fait un embargo
avec l'Irak. l'Irak, les 10 années
d'embargo, c'était des enfants qui
muraient de la rouge
c'était des situations dramatiques sur
le plan humain et ça n'a pas fait tomber
Saddam Hussein. Donc l'embargo n'a
jamais abouti au renversement d'un
régime et en plus maintenant qu'ils ont
inventé la justice extraterritoriale
américaine, ils peuvent prendre
n'importe quelle entreprise étrangère
qui continue à travailler avec l'Iran
pour éventuellement en fonction de ses
avoirs aux États-Unis la condamner.
Donc on est sur un scénario de
construction de l'ennemi dans lesquels
demain on peut très bien avoir un
scénario de guerre.
Les Iraniens dans tout ça, est-ce que
c'est ce qu'on est-ce que c'est ce que
nous ont décrit les médias sur le fait
que c'est
un pays archaïque, un pays rétrograde,
peup de la révolution, peuplé de de
femmes qui se font tabasser,
de gens qui se font pendre.
Euh tu sais, on voit souvent des petites
guitounes dans Paris avec des drapeaux
iraniens, avec toutes les exaions du
gouvernement, avec des réfugiés
politiques derrière. H
est-ce que c'est vrai ça ?
Bah c'est vrai et c'est faux en même
temps. C'est-à-dire qu'encore une fois
si tu fais de la communication, tu vas
choisir ta cible. C'est-à-dire tu vas
dire "Regardez l'Iran c'est comme si
c'est comme ça." Si on regarde les
statistiques par exemple des
associations de dénonciation de la peine
de mort, le nombre d'exécution capitale
en Arabie Saoudite, si tu le rapportes à
la population, est plus important que
même la Chine. Bon, ça veut dire que
l'Arabie Saoudite tient à la tête, si je
puis m'exprimer ainsi, de tous les pays
qui décapitent sur la planète. Si tu
plans le pays de la tolérance, il y a
aucune autre religion qui est tolérée
sur le territoire de l'Arabie Saoudite.
Il t'explique, c'est la terre de
l'Islam. Que je sache, c'est pas Mahomè
qui a tracé les frontières de l'Arabie
Saoudite. Tu as des églises aux Émirats,
tu as des églises au Qatar. Pourquoi
est-ce qu'en Arabie Saoudite, c'est
totalement interdit ? Donc là, on est
dans un pays de l'intolérance absolue.
En Iran, tu as une vieille communauté
juive, tu as des Arméniens qui
pratiquent, tu as même des Arméniens qui
font du vin pour leur culte. Bon, donc
c'est pas du tout le même schéma. Et
enfin de dernière chose, l'Iran, c'est
un pays qui a 3000 ans d'histoire et
l'Arabie Saoudite, c'est un pays qui
commence à apparaître avec le avec le
prophète et qui surtout ne veut pas
connaître son passé. Pour eux, il y a
pas de denté islamique. Le pays
s'éveille avec le prophète. Donc tu as
effectivement des pays qui sont dans
deux catégories totalement différentes
et encore une fois la sensibilisation à
l'égard de l'Iran est
incommensurablement supérieur pour des
raisons de communication d'ailleurs à ce
qui se passe en Arabie Saoudite. Donc
toujours je reviens à ma question c'est
les Saoudiens sont beaucoup plus forts
que les Iraniens en matière de com.
La Chine dans tout ça va se positionner
comment ? Elle va prendre
bah si tu veux le cas de la Chine là
aussi fait partie de ces scénarios
intéressants de fabrication de l'ennemi.
Tu as vu que Trump il a décidé la Chine
être sanctionné et cetera et cetera. Bon
ça s'est un peu arrangé là.
Ouais mais ça avec lui tu sais jamais.
Tu vas te réveiller demain et il va dire
non c'est fini on coupe tous les avoirs
chinois aux États-Unis et cetera.
Donc c'est pas de la c'est pas de la vie
politique si tu veux de normalisation à
long terme. Bon la Chine
ce qui est intéressant c'est que la
Chine va être regardée comme le pays qui
par nature est le perturbateur des
relations internationales
parce que elle continue d'acheter du
pétroli iranien.
Non c'est parce que si tu veux tu vas
voir Huawei on va expliquer que
attention ils ont des des trucs pirates
surtout leur le téléphone portable qu'il
faut les sanctionner parce qu'on peut
pas contrôler ces gens-là et cetera.
Ils font de la concurrence à la NSA. Ah
ben le problème c'est qu'effectivement
ce qu'on sait de la NSA, s'ils sont
aussi forts que la NSA, on est surveillé
par tout le monde. Rappelle-toi que
quand il y a eu le scandale de la NSA,
on a appris que les Américain écoutaient
madame Merkel quand même. Alors que je
sache, on n' pas décidé de couper toutes
les relations avec les États-Unis. Donc
on est dans ce monde de la construction
de l'image. Dans l' dit "Oui, si c'est
chinois, attention c'est ça doit être
sulfureux." En même temps, si les
Chinois posent leurs propres normes en
matière d'internet, tu peux comprendre.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils aient pas envie de
se mettre sous l'autorité des
Américains, tu peux le comprendre. Mais
arrivé à cette pondération qui était la
caractéristique du régime golien de
diplomatie de Gaulle en disant "Mais la
France doit faire sa propre diplomatie
au milieu d'un monde dans lequel il y a
pas obligatoirement des gentils d'un
côté, des méchants de l'autre."
Ça fait longtemps qu'on s'est pas vu.
Est-ce que tu vois des sujets abordés
ensemble avec la communauté ?
Non. Ce que je trouve ce qui me fait
plaisir, c'est de voir que le massacre
continue au Yémen, c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a absolument aucun problème. Il y a
Choléra qui tu à peu près 100000
personnes, que il y a la famine dans les
zones qui ne peuvent pas être desservis
par le truc, qu'il y a des
parlementaires français qui sont allés
faire une visite au Yémen en arrivant
par les Émirats arabes unis
pour venir témoigner de l'aide
humanitaire fournie par l'Arabie
Saoudite et par les Émirats.
Donc, tu te dis qu'il y a du boulot,
quoi.
Comment ça va se finir cette histoire de
Yémen ?
Je sais pas si tu veux le le Yémémen de
d'épine dans le pied de l'Arabie
Saoudite. D'abord c'était euh c'était ce
qu'on appelait l'Arabie heureuse, hein,
le Yémen, c'est-à-dire c'était quand
même le pays dans lequel il y avait des
montagnards qui faisaient de la culture.
Alors que en plein milieu du désert
central d'Arabie Saoudite, c'est avec
des nomades qui faisaient du commerce
nord-sud. Bon, deuxième caractéristique,
les Yéénites sont des combattants. Ils
sont comme les Afghans, les Yéénites,
c'estàd c'est des mecs, tu peux pas
faire la différence entre un combattant
et un non combattant quoi. Ils sont tous
armés.
Et pendant longtemps d'ailleurs, les
Yéénites fournissaient le sature de
l'armée saoudienne.
Et donc aujourd'hui euh le quand le le
régime saoudien quand le HN saou
constitue les limites du territoire
saoudien, il annexe une province yéénite
dans le sud. Bon, donc il y a ce vieux
contentieux entre les deux pays, mais
c'est un pays le Yémémen qui est divisé
entre une partie de communauté chite,
une partie de communauté sunnite. Donc
c'est un pays qui a toujours vécu cet
état de crise. Bon, donc il ne peut y
avoir de solution que s'il y avait
quelque chose qui pourrait ressembler à
de la laïcité dans le monde arabe. Mais
je c'est peut-être un rêve fou. Mais
pour que ces deux parties de communauté
pratiquant le même religion mais avec
des pratiques différentes, la seule
manière de de résoudre le conflit ce
serait effectivement de confier ça à des
Suisses quoi. Tu envoies un un Suisse
qui leur explique comment on peut vivre
ensemble avec des langues différentes,
avec des pratiques différentes. Mais
c'est un saut culturel, hein.
Est-ce que c'est envisageable une
révolution en Arabie Saoudite ? Non, je
crois que le scénario le plus probable,
c'est qu'effectivement Mohamed Ben
Salman a quand même fait plusieurs
opérations qui ont probablement fâché
ses petits cousins. La plus grosse des
opérations, c'est l'affaire du Ritz
Carton. C'est-à-dire que
il a mis dans ce grand hôtel de Riad, il
a appelé 200 de ses petits cousins et
princes diverses et cetera. Il leur a
dit "Venez, on va parler de l'avenir du
royaume." Et puis quand ils sont arrivés
sur place, on leur a piqué leur
téléphone portable, on les a enfermé
dans les chambres et puis ils devaient
tous passer pour dégorger le pognon qui
s'était pris pendant toutes leurs années
de
Gabg,
leurs années heureuses. Bon et donc on
pense que cette opération anticorruption
a rapporté entre 60 et 100 milliards à
peu près hein. Au fur et à mesure que
les types sortaient, il signaient
d'échecs. Bon, deux remarques sur ce
sujet. D'abord,
évidemment, il ils ont pas dû ressortir
très contents, c'est-à-dire que ils ont
l'impression que effectivement tout à
coup, on leur fait rendre l'argent, mais
enfin ils peuvent considérer que on les
prive si tu veux de ce qui était leur
niveau de vie. Par exemple, tous les
contrats d'armement, on les a signé avec
la famille la branche saoudienne des
sultanes. Donc le ministre de la défense
qui est resté pendant 25 ans, c'était
Ben Sulton. C'est son fils qui devait
prendre le magasin et puis tac. Du coup,
il est écarté. C'est un proche de
Mohamed Ben Salman qui va prendre la
suite. Donc il y a probablement à
l'intérieur des familles princies des
gens qui doivent si tu veux machonner
leur ranqueur. Donc ça c'est un scénario
qui est grave. La deuxième chose qui est
intéressante dans cette affaire du RIT
Carlton c'est que tous les mecs qui
avaient pas leur portefeuille sur eux
qui pouvaient pas payer le milliard
demandé il pouvaient céder des actifs.
Et Mohamed Ben Salman prend le contrôle
de tout le groupe Middle East Bootcing
Corporation qui était la propriété d'une
autre branche de la famille et donc il
prend le contrôle. Ça veut dire queil
renforce son pouvoir sur le les médias.
Ça fait partie de sa politique de com.
Donc tu as vu l'efficacité puisque quand
il a fait sa tournée, c'était devenu le
grand réformateur de l'Arabie Saoudite.
Il faisait des interviews partout et on
disait regardez cet homme-là, il va nous
transformer l'Arabie Saoudite.
Le fait que le même mec se paye un
château à Vlouv qui est une copie de
Versailles et un yacht racheté un
oligarque russe qui était d'ailleurs un
ancien. J'ai cru comprendre un yacht que
possédait Trump. 800 millions de
dollars, ça te prouve que c'est pas la
lutte anticorruption qui était son souci
principal, c'est la concentration du
pouvoir. Donc est-ce qu'il y en a un
jour qui va lui planter un couteau dans
le dos pendant que il y aura une fête de
famille ? J'en sais rien, c'est pas
impossible.
Euh, on arrive pratiquement à la fin de
notre interview. Est-ce que tu vois des
des sujets abordés ? Est-ce que on a on
parle on a peut-être pas parlé assez de
Trump ? Est-ce qu'on a pas parlé assez
de SarkoZi ? Euh, tu veux qu'on parle un
peu de la Libye ? Tu veux qu'on parle un
peu de l'Afrique ? Ce qui me désespère
un peu si tu veux, c'est que tu
t'aperçois que
le rythme politique est un rythme
médiatique. C'est-à-dire que si
l'affaire Kachogi s'éteint, ce que ce
que je ne crois souhaite pas aux
Amériques, aux États-Unis, parce que
comme c'est devenu un argumentaire
anti-Trump, ça a plus de chance de vivre
là-bas. Mais en France, tu t'aperçois
que Cachogi maintenant étant
pratiquement réglé, les affaires
reprennent.
Donc tu te dis les massacres se
poursuivent au Yémen. Tu as cette
déclaration extraordinaire de notre
ministre de la défense qui dit mais nous
ne vendons que des armes défensives.
Bien sûr si tu vends des potes de
désignation laser pour des avions, c'est
pas tes potes qui qui tuent, c'est les
missiles qui sont guidés par tes potes
de désignation.
Donc il y a qu' il y a que dans cette
guerre là où on va expliquer qu'une
bonne de 250 kg ça ne tue un terroriste.
Et quand ça tombe sur un hôpital de MSF
par exemple le MSF n'a jamais dénoncé si
tu veux de manière virulente cet
attentat qui a visé un de ses hôpitaux.
Alors tu te dis pourquoi ? Mais parce
que leurs types sont menacés là-bas.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? C'est une
espèce de système si tu veux qui se mort
la queue et qui fait que on a du mal à
soulever le problème dans sa dimension,
dans sa totalité.
Tu as déjà eu des
des gens qui sont venus te parler en
disant "Bon écoute Pierre, tu vas te
calmer un petit peu.
Tu veux pas venir travailler pour nous ?
Je suis très cher, il faut leur dire.
ve maber, il faut qu'il sachent que je
suis très cher. Non non le le truc je
rigole mais si tu veux ce qui m'a le
plus abordé c'est des gens qui
regardentw et qui m'ont dit je vous ai
vu suriew et cetera et cetera donc non
tu je me considère pas comme un
personnage qui menace l'Arabie Saoudite
si tu sais que je seraiis pas invité au
cocktail de l'Arabie Saoudite je ferai
pas le pélerinage cette année mais enfin
qu'est-ce que tu veux faire faut
accepter
qui qui euh
en terme de coufar menace réellement
l'Arabie Saoudite
c'est une bonne question ça. Je crois
qu'il y a tous les pays sont d'accord
sur le fait que tant que ce pays est
aussi riche que celui qui ce qu'il est
et cetera, il y aura pas de diplomatie,
sauf peut-être l'Iran, hein, mais il y
aura pas de diplomatie de stricte
dénonciation de l'Arabie Saoudite. Moi,
ce qui m'a frappé, c'est que les
intellectuels qui sont le plus
dénonciateurs de l'influence du
waabhabisme sont des intellectuels
musulmans. intellectuel musulmans,
c'est-à-dire des gens ou même la presse
arabophone dont je me suis servi pour
l'étude sur le lobby saoudien est
incroyablement plus critique à l'égard
de l'Arabie Saoudite que ne l'it la
diplomatie française. Par exemple,
l'Algérie qui a été sollicité pour venir
dans la coalition pour la guerre au
Yémen a refusé d'y aller en disant "Mais
nous on va pas collaborer avec un pays
qui nous a causé 10 ans de guerre civile
parce qu'ils disent aucun doute sur le
fait que les salafistes, le GIA, le GSPC
et cetera qui leur ont causé tant de
mort, c'était la matrice saoudienne qui
les avait formé." Donc tu te retrouves
avec des pays arabes qui sont beaucoup
plus radicaux dans la dénonciation de
l'Arabie Saoudite que le sont les pays
occidentaux.
Est-ce qu'on peut parler terrorisme
immigrant ?
On en est où des des flots de migrants ?
On en est où de l'infiltration des flots
de migrants par les terroristes ? Est-ce
que c'est avéré ? C'est pas avéré ?
C'est une légende ? C'est quoi ?
Je sais pas. Moi, j'ai pas d'information
là-dessus mais parce que en fait
le les attentats qu'on a connu étaient
des attentats qui étaient pilotés depuis
le la Syrie Irak mélangeant des gens
dans les les flots de migrants pour
venir faire les opérations de 2015-2
2016 ici. Voilà.
Donc l'idée des flots de micron contrôlé
infiltré si tu veux, je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup plus
difficile à déterminer. Puis de toute
façon, on n'a pas fait le lien entre le
phénomène des migrants et le phénomène
du terrorisme. La deuxième chose qui
malheureusement est inquiétante, c'est
que tous les tentatives d'attentat qu'on
a connu depuis la disparition de l'État
islamique, c'est du terrorisme endogène,
c'est-à-dire des gens qui peuvent encore
se mobiliser pour tirer dans le tas,
pour intervenir dans une fête et cetera
et cetera.
Ça me désespère un peu parce que si tu
veux, tu as encore toute une mécanique
qui essaie de travailler sur le
financement du terrorisme, mais les
attentats qu'on a connu depuis la
disparition de l'État islamique, ce sont
des attentats bon marché. Donc c'est
plus la lutte contre le financement
qu'il faut chasser, c'est la lutte
contre l'idéologie.
Si on ne se bat pas sur le terrain de
l'idéologie, on aura toujours des mecs.
Tant qu'on confond la Tu sais, il y a un
imam, un imam français qui m'a dit "Vous
savez le whabisme, c'est la version la
plus raciste, la plus antisémite, la
plus homophobe, la plus sexiste, la plus
raciste de l'islam."
Alors, tu te dis "Mais pourquoi on
n'applique pas la loi Gesso au
prédicateur salafiste ?"
Posons la question à nos autorités. Si
un type d'extrême droit tient le
discours d'un salafiste, tout le monde
va lui tomber dessus en disant "Marine
Le Pen, mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on on ne
regarde ce discours ? Non, on dit que
c'est de la liberté de conscience mais
ça a jamais été de la liberté de
conscience d'être antisémite.
Donc pourquoi encore une fois fait-on
semblant de respecter ce genre de chos ?
On a réussi, je crois, à expulser
une douzaine d'imames à peu près, ce qui
prouve que quand même la lutte
antisalafiste progresse à grand pas.
Tu vois la France comment dans 5 ans ?
difficile à dire parce que si tu veux le
champ politique français, il est
complexe mais pour des raisons qui ont
pas grandchose à voir avec le ce qui se
passe là-bas. Sauf le fait
qu'effectivement la crise des migrants a
révélé et en particulier la crise des
gilets jaunes a révélé que si tu veux
mélanger la fonction d'accueil de la
France et en même temps la situation de
désérance d'un certain nombre de
quartiers et d'un certain nombre de
gens. On pas on n pas accueilli grand
monde
pardon. On n'a pas accueilli grand
monde.
On n'a pas accueilli de On
n'a pas accueilli grand monde.
On n'a pas accueilli grand monde. Mais
il reste que c'est encore une fois c'est
la dimension médiatique de la chose qui
est importante. C'est-à-dire tu te
retrouves avec des euh un débat qui vite
va commencer à s'emballer.
Le la France se tient à peu près en
matière de nombre de d'accueils de
migrants. C'est moins que l'Allemagne
mais enfin c'est pas non plus la
Grande-Bretagne n'oublie pas ferme ses
frontières hein. S'il y a le problème de
calé c'est parce que les les
britanniques
Danemark
ou le Danemark. Ouais. Bon, donc on est
quand même dans des situations où on est
au milieu de tableau si tu veux hein.
Bon, mais le
quand les Français effectivement comme
ceux qui sont manifestés sur les gilets
jaunes, si tu veux expliqu le problème
des retraites et cetera, l'idée de
prendre en charge des gens qu'il faut
accueillir parce qu'ils sont encore dans
une situation plus désespérée queeux
ressort à ce moment-là le fait que dans
les manifestations des gilets jaunes, tu
avais des drapeaux français. Tu vois ce
que je veux dire ? C'estàd des gens qui
disaient "Mais pensez un peu à nous."
Et c'est vrai que tu as l'impression
qu'il y a des élites françaises qui sont
pas descendu sur terre depuis déjà bien
longtemps. Moi j'étais une si tu veux
j'ai une
un exemple d'un type avec qui j'ai
travaillé qui est un type remarquable,
très intelligent et cetera. Mais si tu
fais non, je si tu fais sa trajectoire,
c'est un type qui a fait de bonnes
études, qui a fait une classe prépa qui
a fait normal sup qui ensuite après a
fait l'ENAT, qui ensuite est sorti dans
le Conseil d'État, qui ensuite fait du
cabinet. Ça veut dire que c'est un type
qui pendant 15 ans n'a pas posé les
pieds sur terre et tout de suite il
devient en responsabilité.
Donc si tu n'introduis pas dans cette
manière de recruter des élites des
moments où les types sont obligés de
prendre leur sac à dos pour se passer un
an dans une ONG, un an dans une
ambassade, non même pas dans une
ambassade à l'étranger, c'est trop bien
l'ambassade à l'étranger. Mais tu vois
quelque chose qui fasse qu'on découvre
autre chose, un programme Erasmus mais
vrai, tu vois, tu te dis pourquoi
veux-tu qu'il pense même la France dans
des conditions ? Quand tu es
ambassadeur, que tu vends la France,
quel contact as-tu avec la France ? tu
as un niveau de vie extraordinaire, tu
as pratiquement tout ce qu'il te faut
autour de toi, tu as un discours
officiel dans lequel il faut clair
t'explique que la France est paye des
droits de l'homme et cetera et cetera.
Pourquoi l'Arabie Saoudite commence à
regarder le nucléaire de très près ?
C'est parce qu'ils anticipent la fin du
pétrole, ils veulent s'armer de de la
bombe. Non ou c'est la bombe. C'est la
bombe. Il y a aucun doute si tu veux.
Bon, il y a une bombe qui s'est qualifié
à un moment d'islamique qui était la
bombe pakistanaise. Les pakistanais ont
expliqué que leur programme s'était
aussi destiné à défendre le reste du
monde de musulmans et cetera. Bon, on y
croit qu'à moitié parce que si tu veux,
tu vas pas utiliser une bombe si c'est
pas pour sanctualiser ton territoire.
C'est une espèce de contradiction dans
les termes. Mais enfin, ça veut dire que
le savoir-faire est à proximité, que les
relations entre l'Arabie Saoudite et le
Pakistan sont excellentes. Et donc si à
terme il devait y avoir besoin, il y
aurait probablement des la technologie,
des ingénieurs qui pourraient venir et
cetera. Mais tu vas pas mettre les
Saoudiens au travail demain.
Quand tu es dans une pays d'économie
rentière depuis pratiquement la
découverte du pétrole, c'est depuis le
début du 20e siècle, les mecs sont
habitués à pas payer l'électricité, à
pas payer l'eau et avoir des des
ressources s veulent faire leurs études
à l'étranger et cetera. Comment veux-tu
demander à des mecs de devenir
ingénieurs nucléaires, faire travailler
et pour ça ? Il y a tous les bouges qui
travaillent en Arabie Saoudite. Quand
les types viennent là-bas, si tu t'en
parles avec des Marocains, des Algériens
qui travaillent là-bas, ils sont traités
comme des chiens.
Et c'est eux qui font le boulot. Donc tu
te retrouves
traités ils sont traités comme dirait un
de mes amis qui est marocain ils sont
traités comme des rouains. Ils sont
considérés comme les roumains. C'est le
Maghreb pour les l'Arabie Saoudite c'est
les Roumains.
Ouais si tu veux. On a eu un cas. Moi,
je lui ai vécu quand j'étais à la
délégation générale pour l'armement. On
leur avait vendu le
respect qu'on a pour les Roumains
d'ailleurs.
Ah oui oui bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr.
Mais si tu veux on leur avait vendu les
frégates Sawari 2. Donc il y avait tout
un problème de formation des cadres des
officiers et cetera et cetera. Donc on
les prend à Toulon pour faire du de la
formation. Bon, ils arrivent avec leur
famille et ils demandent qu'on leur
construise une école. Alors dit "Mais
attendez, il y a l'école publique
française, vous mettez vos enfants
là-bas et cetera." Et les mecs, ils
assistaient, non, on veut notre école et
cetera. Ils voulaient pas les mettre à
Toulon parce que Toulon, c'est plein
d'arabes, c'est des Maghrébains. Tu vas
pas demander à que leurs enfants ils
fassent leurs études avec les
Maghrébains. Je veux dire, pour eux,
c'est la preuve même de la dégradation
de l'enseignement français. Donc, on
leur a construit une école.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Psychologiquement, tous les types qui
reviennent du golf, ils en reviennent
avec la haine si tu veux rapport qu'ils
ont eu avec les indigènes saoudiens. On
a une question de l'ours sur notre forum
qui dit "L'arrêt de l'arrêt de la vente
d'armes à l'Arabie Saoudite
augmenterait-el le risque d'attentat en
France
Non, ça alors vraiment c'est une
question difficile hein parce que
effectivement euh
non les Saoudiens ont jamais mis les
mains dans le camboui pour organiser
parce qu'encore une fois la survie de la
dynastie
quand même des lasagnes avec le leurs
citoyens dans les ambassades. Oui, mais
si tu veux c'est encore une fois, c'est
la catégorie des princes féons,
c'est-à-dire les gens qui ont qui ont
bénéficié du système et qui ensuite de
l'étranger trahissent. Kashogi c'était
la le l'ennemi par nature puisqu'il
était correspondant d'un grand média
américain. Donc lui c'était le type qui
avait le plus comment dire de capacité
de nuisance sur le régime. C'est pour ça
qu'il en a terminé en petit morceau.
Donc encore une fois, on n'est pas dans
un système où les Saoudiens, ils mettent
pas les mains dans le cambouille parce
que la survie du régime est plus
importante que le reste. Non, ils ont
formé des gens qui ont pris leur
indépendance si tu veux. Le docteur
Frankenstein a créé des monstres. Ces
monstres se retournent contre le docteur
Frankenstein, mais nous on voudrait
sauver le docteur Frankenstein. Or le
dans le roman de Marie Chellé, tu te
souviens qu'il meurent tous les deux.
Mais nous, on voudrait dire non, il faut
protéger la dynastie. Il y a eu des
attentats contre les compagnes
américains après la guerre du golf. Il y
a eu des attentats contre la dynastie et
cetera. Encore une fois, dans le golf,
Al-Qaïda dans la péninsule arabique est
considérée par la CIA comme la broche la
plus dangereuse d'Al-Qaïda. Mais si tu
veux, c'est leurs enfants quoi.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview.
Est-ce que tu as trois bouquins à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
Pas les miens, tu veux dire ?
Ça non, ça j'aime pas trop ça.
Euh trois bouquins à conseiller.
Comment il s'appelle ton dernier bouquin
?
Euh moi le dernier bouquin, on a fait
l'interview, c'était sur Hollyw, tu
sais, sur Hollywood comme de propagande
massive.
On a dit trois autres.
Euh le
Qu'est-ce que j'ai lu de très
significatif ? Là, je suis en train de
lire un bouquin de je crois que c'est un
algérien qui s'appelle Redici qui
justement sur l'islamit, il est il dit
comment l'islam sectaire est devenu
l'islam dominant. Donc c'est tout le
processus d'affluence de l'Arabie
Saoudite sur l'islam un peu partout sur
la planète.
Euh qu'est-ce que j'ai lu de d'autres
très intéressants encore récemment ? Euh
les
vous me prenez un peu de cours, j'ai pas
réfléchi à la question.
Euh pour sortir des
lectures des lectures pour cet été sur
la plage, hein. Oui, j'ai bien compris.
J'ai bien compris mais c'est parce que
si tu veux, j'étais tellement dedans
dans le mon sujet que je réfléchis sur
Alors, je te casse une question de
Mononoké. Quelle est la puissance
actuelle de rébellion des Yéénites face
à l'Arabie Saoudite ? Y a-t-il des
d'autres pays qui s'y attaquent
qui s'attaquent à l'Arabie Saoudite ou
qui s'attaquent aux Yéénite ?
Qui on va faire les deux mais je pense
plutôt qu'il s'attaque à l'Arabie
Saoudite
parce que l'Arabie Saoudite a voulu
créer une une coalition sunnite
pour taper sur les les outils qui sont
des chiites. Bon donc il y a bien
effectivement des pays euh la majorité
sunite qui ont participé qui participent
militairement à la campagne mais il y a
des pays qui ont refusé. par exemple le
le l'Algérie, je t'ai cité l'exemple, où
le Maroc a refusé aussi d'y aller. Bon,
donc on a en tout cas une coalition du
côté des forces qui sont armées et du
côté euh des outils, il doit
certainement y avoir des passes d'Aran
qui sont venus d'Iran. Ça c'est fort
probable. Il y en a peut-être qui sont
venus d'Irak encore parce que la
solidarité sunit cheit ou enfin ou
l'onimosité s'unit cheit est devenue en
fait structurant dans le Moyen-Orient.
Aujourd'hui, si tu regardes bien, il y a
le Pakistan, l'Afghanistan, la Syrie,
l'Irak, le Yémen, Bahrain et même le
Nigéria dans lequel il y a une guerre
sunite chiite. La question que je me
pose en tant que occidental, c'est
est-ce qu'on doit intervenir dans cette
guerre ?
Donc, on arrive à la dernière question
qui n'est pas une question, c'est
laisser un conseil pour les jeunes
générations, quelque chose
d'impérissable, quelque chose qui va
rester sur les réseaux.
Il y a une phrase Il y a une phrase de
Gérard Chalian que je trouve assez
intéressante. Il dit "La capacité des
anciennes victimes à devenir des
bourreaux laisse bien augurer de
l'avenir de l'espèce."
C'est-à-dire que si tu veux, comme le
travail de la victimisation est un
argument de politique internationale
aujourd'hui, si on se rend pas compte
que les victimes peuvent devenir des
bourreaux, on est toujours décalé d'une
guerre.
Pierre connaissa, merci.
Merci à vous.
[Musique]